e
e e
going to open the hearing on HB 577 I'll
rise for the Pledge of Allegiance
will you leave
us represent
us States of America and to the repblic
for stands one nation God
indiv and justice for all thank
you okay chair recognizes representative
Alexander can you please make sure you
fill out a pink card these doing it
right
now
thanks it's
situated good morning um chairman Cole
members of the House housing committee
for the record my name is Joe Alexander
I represent the town of
gtown um thank you for the opportunity
today in um to speak before you in
support of House Bill
577 as you are all well aware New
Hampshire is currently facing a housing
crisis that demands our immediate
attention and action according to recent
data New Hampshire has seen an alarming
shortage of affordable housing with an
estimated 20,000 new homes needed to
meet demand rental prices have soared by
over 20% over the past few years and
many residents particularly younger
people seniors and those in low-income
brackets are finding it increasingly
difficult to find suitable housing
within their needs the lack of
affordable housing is not just an
economic issue it's a community issue
families are being displaced young
professionals are leaving for more
affordable areas and seniors are
struggling to stay in their homes as
property taxes and housing costs rise
one critical solution that we can
Implement immediately to help address
this crisis is to make it easier for
homeowners to build accessory dwelling
units or adus currently the law allows
municipalities to regulate adus but
these regulations very widely creating
confusion and unnecessary barriers for
homeowners who wish to build or or
convert an Adu on their property adus
provide a flexible and efficient way to
create additional living space whether
for aging relatives as I'm sure you'll
hear hear about young adults just
starting out or as rental units to help
homeowners meet riseing costs
unfortunately some municipalities have
adopted overly restrictive rules that
limit property owner's ability to
exercise their rights HB 577 seeks to
address this imbalance by creating a
more form and reasonable framework for
adus across a St a state this bill
ensures property owners have the right
to build an Adu on their property as
long as it meets reasonable safety and
Zoning standards it preserves local
control where necessary but removes
restrictions upon Property Owners
ability to use their land effectively HB
577 enables a property owner to build an
Adu by right up to 950 Square ft and the
property owner can choose whether the
Adu is detached or attach the main unit
a key provision in this
bill moreover it's important to note
that the current law already recognizes
the value and potential of adus the
issue lies in the fact that many of the
restrictions imposed by municipalities
make it difficult costly and sometimes
impossible for homeowners to take
advantage of of this option this bill
balances the need for local oversight
with a fundamental right of property
owners to make decisions about their own
land by supporting HB 577 this commun
this committee will be standing up for
the principles of private property
rights and giving homeowners the tools
they need to contribute to solving the
housing shortage in New Hampshire it's a
bill that benefits homeowners
strengthens communities and aligns with
our broader goals of expanding
affordable housing options in conclusion
I urge the committee to support 577
you'll see from the speakers following
me that this is a bill that has broad
support across all of New Hampshire's
communities it's a common sense approach
that supports property rights while
addressing our state's growing housing
needs let's work together make it easier
for homeowners to contribute to the
solution thank you I'm happy to answer
questions thank you there are any
questions representative Reed thank you
Mr chair thank you representative as you
are very well familiar this is an issue
I've worked on for years and I'm very
passionate about and I thank you for
offering to put it in in our current
environment for me um so I did notice
that you removed uh a piece and that
piece is um the providing that a town on
a second Adu which I realized she took
out the right for the second Adu but any
additional beyond the first Adu that a
town may require Workforce housing uh
rent levels and My worry is upon
removing that and I'm not saying I'm
against the bill because you know I am
very passionately for the bill um but
removing that what that allows is for uh
adus to be built for the short-term
rental market which would be detrimental
for our housing market it would further
add to the very many um factors that are
increasing our housing costs so um can
you speak to how that would not be a
concern in your current wording well
thank you for the question and
representative Reed thank you again for
the bipartisan work that we've done in
the past fews on this bill um you've
been a leader on this issue um what what
I would say is yes that provision was
removed I am not not against
language that would clarify the
short-term rental provision because if
you're looking for long-term rentals or
you know or rentals for seniors or
something like that that wouldn't be a
short qualify as a short-term rental um
I'm not against adding that language
back into
it yes thank you chair I just I like the
bill I just had a clarifying question on
page two line three um if I'm reading
that correctly does that mean that there
has to be a door between the two units
and I was just wondering for
clarification why thank you um I believe
that and I'm I'm sure somebody will
correct me if I'm wrong there's I'm sure
people a lot to speak but I believe
that's the current law that would
require the if per attach would require
the unit to share a wall or a door in
between in between the two units that
would would be how I would read attached
but are there any other questions
representative Reed Mr chair this isn't
a question I just wanted to clarify the
point just raised if you would allow me
should yes that's um that is current
well current laws said that the
municipality could choose and this
language is based on the previous Bill's
language which removes that choice it
just says that the Ingress or egress has
to there has to be an Ingress and egress
point it can be external it can be
internal it's up to the person building
not the
town thank you there any other
questions thank you representative thank
you all right I see a lot of cards here
and everyone wrote down three minutes
thank you so much for that I will'll
call on Matt
Mayberry good morning Mr Vice chairman
committee members my name is Matt
Mayberry I'm the CEO of the New
Hampshire homebuilders
Association and I'm the one who the
primary author of this build to come
before you folks to support so thank you
for moving
forward we represent the 27,000 women
and men who work within the residential
home building industry we contribute 5.4
billion doar into our state's economy
and we along with you are at the
Forefront of the state's most
challenging issue
housing I watched the legislator's
efforts last session to pass an Adu bill
it was far reaching and perhaps a little
too far in that reach so recently the
home builders in collaboration with
chairman Alexander representative Reed
the Bia the New Hampshire Realtors the
New Hampshire Housing and Finance
Authority neighborworks talk about a
collaborative effort in
that to bring you today a comprehensive
collaborative and effective measure to
address the housing needs on all levels
HP 577 before you here are the facts
this will allow by right meaning that
the municipality cannot say no but
instead how can we make this work
currently you must seek permission from
municipality if this passes that no
longer applies units must be limited to
950 square units or above but above that
correction is limited to 950 Square ft
if you want to go above that you work
with your municipality to design and
build one that's
larger it's limited to one unit attached
to a detached you can have separate
electrical service if you wish there's
no familiar requirement your septic and
water draw must be able to sustain this
added unit if you have a two-bedroom
septic system and you're trying to add a
two-bedroom unit you have a
challenge this works within the original
framework that we have
now the town needs to work with you on
the Aesthetics a treehouse or a pirate
ship probably wouldn't be an acceptable
aesthetic or even a practical Adu
the Adu must be constructed to code
building permits are still required and
the town can no longer limit you to or
cannot limit you to one bedroom so with
that 950 if you want two-bedroom unit I
came with a 950 because I lived in
condominium that was two-bedroom two
bath 850 Square ft and that suited my
needs just
fine this will allow people stay in
their homes longer help them pay their
mortgages and property taxes but most
important and immediate this helps
infill a lot of the urban areas which
cuts down the
sprawl and this also Pro provides
attainable housing for those who are
working hard every single day the New
Hampshire homeb Builder Association are
in full and strong support of HB 577 and
encourage you to do the same please
thank
you thank you do we have any
questions seeing none thank you very
much
okay Sarah
[Music]
Holland good morning my name is Sarah
Holland I am a real estate broker in
central New Hampshire and I'm the
current chair of the public policy
committee for the New Hampshire
Association of Realtors the Realtors ask
you to support HB
577 and in December we conducted a
survey of New Hampshire residents and we
asked them if they support the current
law requiring municipalities to allow an
attached Adu and 90% said that they
supported that statute we then asked if
they would ex support expanding the law
to allow either an attached or a
detached Adu by right and 81% supported
the concept and this bill in front of
you is just that so it's not surprising
that we're seeing this type of report
considering the same survey showed that
half of our residents are not confident
that they could find adequate housing in
their Community if they had to move
Realtors see this housing anxiety every
day parents who have um aging children
are unable to afford housing families
who have elderly parents can no longer
live independently and caregivers who
need to find Housing close by those that
they are caring for accessory dwelling
units need to be an option
so think of two families they live on
the same road a mile apart but in
different towns they each have lived in
their home for decades never thinking
nor worrying
about that the time might come when they
need to take care of a parent or a child
one family is allowed to build an Adu
because they live on one side of the
Town Line the other family is prohibited
from doing so because they happen to
just live on the other side of that town
line property private property rights
should not be extinguished because youve
crossed a Town Line the state has a
proper role to play to protect all
residents and their basic property
rights keep in mind under this bill as
previously stated if a property owner
cannot provide adequate septic for an
Adu they cannot build it if they don't
have access to water they cannot build
it if the Adu does not have an adequate
buffer from Wetlands or neighboring
properties then they cannot build you
have to adhere to all Town ordinances
and building requirements this build
does not change that we sometimes hear
claims that an Adu will impact property
values of neighboring homes there's no
evidence to suggest that this is true in
fact published data shows that an Adu
increases the value of the property and
it's important to note that building an
Adu is not
inexpensive logic would then suggest
that if my property inre increases in
value that does not mean my neighbor
goes down and generally it's quite the
opposite my property value raises so
does my neighbors there are plenty of
communities in New Hampshire some which
would be considered affin or wealthier
towns which currently allow for detached
adus there's been no complaints that
have Arisen from those neighboring
Property Owners or that values have
decreased so this is an one of those
important steps to alleviating our
state's housing crisis as you'll hear
lots of stories today so we we ask you
to please support HB 577
thank you there any
questions see none thank you very
much okay I'm sorry if I put you this
name Brian shirell did I say that
correctly all
right thank you very much Mr chairman my
name is and members of the housing
committee my name is Brian chirichello
uh I'm a Dairy resident um I am a real
estate agent I've been a real estate
agent for 25 years but I'm here to
represent myself and I want to paint a
picture uh of of what I am going through
in the town of Derry 10 years ago I
built an oversized 2car garage now my
house is let me back up my house is
1903 it's a
1356 foot New Englander on a third of an
acre I'm on Town water and town sewer 10
years ago I built
a a oversized two-car garage on the
property and up above it I uh I I made a
man cave uh okay to watchh
football still have the furniture up
there still have the TV up there the bar
the whole n yards but interestingly
enough I don't use it anymore it's
roughly a little bigger than 550 square
feet but in the town the town of dairy
does not allow me on Water and Sewer to
make that an Adu because their
requirement is it has to be
attached I mean I suppose I could get a
2x4 and nail it on one side and the
other but you know I'm not about to do
that my point is is that this particular
this particular Bill if you want to um
solve the affordability issue this is
really the perfect Bill to do that um
because when you're Building Homes
you're got to buy land we're not buying
land in a lot of cases we' you've
already got that land and in my case
I've already got that space sitting
there now the benefit to me is as I'm
getting older I could rent that out at
an affordable rate of let's I'm just
throwing a number out there $1,500 a
month in my town I think the average
rent is 2500 and I'm the fourth largest
in the in the in the state the fourth
largest community I'd be more than happy
to rent that out for $1,500 a month to
somebody that that's in crisis or a
traveling nurse or somebody that's just
starting out so
yes I I guess I could go to zoning board
um but then I've got to prove a hardship
and I don't think that that's necessary
if you want to tackle
affordability this bill does the job I
think this is a very very good bill and
I would urge you to pass that thank you
I'll take any questions if anyone has
any thank you thank you there any
questions seeing none thank you very
much Notch
Gra NCH sorry thank you thank you Mr
chair n Grace for the business and
industry Association we are the
Statewide Chamber of Commerce I want to
thank the uh we support this legislation
I want to thank the sponsor for bringing
it forward the co-sponsors and along
with a number of other members of the
legislature and past members of the
legislature in this room who have worked
on this over the years um we believe
this is a sensible update to the 2017
Adu law as you just heard uh we have a
number of examples antidotal examples
across the state of really kind of
bizarre requirements that don't make a
lot of sense where we could add
additional housing units um not only for
traveling nurses but often times for
family members and they just can't be
utilized uh given the given the current
state of things um so this strikes a
great balance uh between local control
and um and also uh the need to do more
with housing because it still requires
that uh you know people building adus
follow all of those local processes and
local codes as Mr Mayberry pointed out
um but it does open up the ability to uh
to develop these sensible units um to a
wider audience here and IT addresses a
number of issues uh that have been um
raised over the years like the water
septic sewer issue uh and and um along
with the conversion of some unused
buildings that are already on property
so I'll leave it at that but I'm
certainly happy to take any questions
the committee may have thank you there
any
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you Sharon
Monroe sure why not I'll just pipe in
okay shortly yes today you get two for
the price of one um I'm Stephanie Skyler
and Sharon and I represent the 212
th000 um ARP members in New Hampshire
and we wholeheartedly endorse HB
577 um from our point of view um it will
support family caregivers a key issue in
New Hampshire facilitate Aging in place
strengthen intergenerational living
expand affordable housing options and
address Workforce housing needs I get
into more detail in my written testimony
which hard copies are here so you don't
have to remember things um one story
that I'd like to share with you that
demonstrates some of these benefits one
of our members talked about one of her
granddaughters who recently with her
partner moved into an Adu and this Adu
was built by an elderly gentleman who
was about ready to retire uh by her
moving in there it was a win-win for
both parties um she was struggling to
find housing and was able to find an
affordable housing unit and the landlord
one because he's going to be getting
income to help him in his golden years
so that's one story and now I'll turn it
over to Sharon to tell another story
well actually that was my story
but so anyway we're on the same page
which is great so good morning um
members of the House housing committee
my name is Sharon Monroe and I'm also a
volunteer in um for AARP so actually I
was at a social Gathering a couple of
weeks ago and the you know people
started talking about housing and
accessory dwelling units how the impact
is on their um family members and this
was a situation where their
granddaughter was just entering in the
workforce and oh and they were uh just
entering in the workforce and they
couldn't find any available housing or
afford it and actually it was um an
elderly gentleman in a house that um he
rented the AG you to this young couple
and they were very happy and independent
starting out um and then his plan was to
um when he retired move into the Adu
himself and then rent out a house which
could free up you know housing for a
larger family um so anyway I think that
story um is similar to Stephanie's and
it exemplifies how adus can benefit our
communities by not only creating more
housing but also allowing for additional
income for older adults as they near
retirement and a limited income um thank
you for listening and I ask that you
consider passing this legislation which
is a step forwards to Al toward
alleviating the housing shortage in our
state any questions thank you do we have
any questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you for
sh Nick Taylor
good morning members of the House
housing committee I'm Nick Taylor I'm
the executive director of housing action
New Hampshire we're a Statewide advocacy
organization that supports increased
access to housing our members include
developers homeless shelters lenders
property managers and more uh we're here
in strong support of House Bill 577 you
a lot of the points that have been made
won't repeat them around affordability
around property rights but we just
really find adus to be a fantastic
attainable housing option that really
adds to our communities without you know
making a huge um impact in terms of how
neighborhoods feel it's a great
opportunity with the garages barns
existing structures the standardization
that comes from this right now about
half communities in New Hampshire allow
for detached adus half don't there's a
patchwork of regulatory framework that
makes it diffic difficult for the market
to mature in terms terms of contractors
and developers that specialize in
building adus it also makes it difficult
for lenders to assess the risk in terms
of you know creating construction loans
and products that make sense for people
to be able to build uh adus in their
communities we have started to seen some
Community Banks lend in this space and
create products because there's a strong
desire this will just continue to unlock
that market and is a great you know
solution for New Hampshire so happy to
take any questions thank you any
questions seeing none thank you very
much V from Peterboro I can't read the
first
name was is it oh Ivy welcome iy I'm
still Ivy van from Peterboro uh thank
you for letting me speak as you know
this is a thing I care deeply about um I
am a land use planner um I'm a certified
land use planner I've been working oh
gosh 10 or 15 years now I have done a
lot of Housing Opportunity planning
Grant work
for about 12 or 14 towns in New
Hampshire in the last two years and one
of the things that I have seen over and
over and over again is Adu ordinances in
individual towns that don't make any
sense and that are clearly had been
adopted to restrict the construction of
accessory dwelling units accessory
dwelling units
are they're just so cute we should you
know and and and we talk we talk about
this in the work that I do a lot whether
things are cute or not is actually
important and you know we we know that
we need housing and you know people when
you say well we need to build more
housing in neighborhoods what people
imagine is a 40 unit Lite building and
that's not that's never what I'm talking
about I'm always talking about
house-sized multifamilies but even even
smaller and more Charming are accessory
dwelling units and they feel a huge need
um as everyone has said before me
they're great for people who are
starting out they're great for people
whose house has gotten too big for them
all of those things and having the Adu
ordinances uniform across the state is
really important it makes it easier for
those Niche developers who are building
adus to be sure that they can do that
it's better for the banks for the
lending it's better for everyone I mean
I have seen accessory dwelling unit
ordinances that require not only an
interior door but that the space between
the main house and the and the Adu be
heated I've seen ordinances require four
parking places for an Adu this seems
outrageous um and I'm just delighted
with this building it's sort of
everything I would ever have asked for
it's what I tell towns they ought to do
the other thing that I want to talk
about just briefly is the whole question
of short-term rental towns can restrict
that and that's a thing for towns to do
individually the one thing I would
remind the board of or the committee of
sorry is that um building an Adu is not
cheap and sometimes in order to make the
money work to create another unit you
need to be able to short-term rent that
unit for some amount of time um and
that's just an economic fact we know
that even before well we don't know
what's going to happen with lumber
prices but even before the UN current
uncertainty about lumber prices we know
that um square foot prices are between 3
and a/4 and 375 a square foot and that's
you know that's IKEA cabinets friends
and neighbors that is not fancy adus
tend to be
expensive um per square foot because
they're small and you have to have all
the parts for a bigger unit in that
smaller unit and sometimes the numbers
just won't work unless you can get the
higher price of a of a short-term rental
and here's the thing once a unit exists
then it can become all kinds of things
over the course of its life it it may
not be a short-term rental forever it
may only be a short-term rental for a
year or so because frankly having a
short-term rental is annoying um people
think that this is going to be a really
swell idea but changing those sheets and
cleaning those bathrooms once a week GH
um so I would just caution the committee
about putting restrictions about whether
or not the Adu can be used as a
short-term rental for those reasons
um and I think I've said everything I
wanted to say anybody have any questions
thank you are there any questions from
the committee see none thank
you okay I'll be back in a
bit
Matt
mushan all
right uh good morning to the house
committee on housing my name is Matt
mushan I live in Claremont and I serve
as The Advocate engagement director for
603 Ford nonpartisan nonprofit
organization dedicated to uh empowering
young people across New Hampshire I am
here today to testify in support of
House Bill
577 uh to expand the definition of
accessory dwelling units and remove
barriers uh that limit their development
um you know you'll hear you've heard
from a lot of folks today so to
summarize um adus have a lot of benefits
for retirees and seniors in the granite
state but also for young people who are
just starting out and finding it
increasingly difficult to afford homes
uh near their jobs uh their families and
the communities that they want to stay
in um as the cost of living continues to
rise it's important more now than ever
to create housing options that meet the
diverse needs of people at different
stages of their life and uh House Bill
577 would do that I personally know the
impact of uh accessory dwelling units
and they that they can have on
affordability I live in a home with an
Adu um my partner uh dad lives with us
and it's made a significant difference
in our ability to afford living uh in
our community and staying there um so I
that's from my own personal experience
why I would urge you to support House
Bill 577 um this bill matters because it
creates more housing choices it creates
more affordable uh accessible housing
Cho options for everyone removes
barriers to adus and it meets the
diverse housing needs of our state um by
passing this bill you could uh help make
New Hampshire more affordable uh and
livable for people at all stages of life
and so why we urge you to vote uh a to
pass on House Bill 577 thank you and I
would take any questions thank you there
are any questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much see you
later Grace
Murray good morning Mr chairman and uh
members of the committee my name is
Grace Murray and I live in Amherst and I
work as the political director of New
Hampshire youth movement and I'm here to
testify in support of HB
577 I've talked to hundreds of young
people and college students about the
issues they care about and
unsurprisingly housing is one of the
biggest stressors for a young person in
New Hampshire today as a college student
housing is stressful because most people
can't afford to live in school provided
housing because of the high cost and
there's never enough off-campus housing
to go around it honestly doesn't get
much better after graduation I've had
many friends move out of state because
of the lack of housing here even though
they wanted to stay these people were
teachers lab techs nurses and more New
Hampshire would benefit from having more
young people in these professions but
because there were no homes for them
they had to
leave I grew up in New Hampshire I went
to school here and I plan on continuing
to live to live here but if our housing
Supply doesn't increase the choice to
stay in New Hampshire might not be up to
me
the thing is I don't want to leave New
Hampshire I have really deep roots here
and I'm heavily involved in my community
I spent a lot of time and effort
building my life here and I don't think
that I or any other young person should
be forced to move out of a state we love
just because our housing shortage has
been left to municipalities to fix local
government has had decades to address
this problem but the housing crisis is
just getting worse and it's time for
Statewide Solutions cutting the red tape
for property owners to build accessory
dwelling units is the kind of strong
legislation that will make a POS
positive impact on the young people in
New Hampshire adus can be rented out to
a student a recent graduate or someone
else with a modest income for college
students and graduates adus can also be
a great opportunity to live near work in
school in a smaller space at a lower
cost while also remaining close to
amenities these units have a low impact
on the neighborhoods that they're in
while also having a high payoff uh
towards the crisis that we're
facing we need more places that college
students graduates and young Working
Families just starting out can afford
and that's exactly what this legislation
would result in I urge you all to
support HB 577 and give young people a
chance to stay in our state thank you
thank you any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much Brody
desar okay but I'm Sarah Burt Cohen I
think you put both of us yep
um so my name is good morning my name is
Sarah Burke Cohen I uh represent the New
Hampshire Municipal Association the new
New Hampshire Municipal Association
opposes the spell
um municipalities
um this would um make a local uh zoning
mandate for mun municipalities as you
all know every municipality is different
um it mandates um it creates a zoning
density issue um which is going to put a
lot of stress on on infrastructures that
are already stressed out um we also feel
like there are no requirements that um I
think one of the representative Reed
might have brought up that any of these
adus will be anything more than um
short-term uh rentals there's nothing
that says that these adus will be
affordable housing or requiring them to
be Workforce housing which will probably
not solve the problem for housing in New
Hampshire um with that um like I said
the nhma opposes this based on the fact
that local control of whether adus are
built needs to remain with the local uh
local governance um in order for um
these towns and mun these towns and
cities to know what's best for their
residents and for the health and safety
of their residents and their
infrastructure I'll take questions thank
you there any questions from the
committee yes representative deont hi
thank you um could you tell me what the
major difference would be from what the
way the law is today versus this bill
other than obviously a conjoining
wall I think that the major difference
right now is the detached right it's
it's adding a detached unit um I think
the other issue we have um which I
actually thank you for your question um
it also uh takes out the ability for a
municipality to determine the lot size
um as you know
uh lot sizes can be problematic and this
needs to stay in local control as well
um because if you have a detached
accessory unit it could require um an
increase in the lot size and this bill
takes that ability for a municipality to
determine whether a increased lot side
is necessary
out there any other questions
representative Reed thank you Mr chair
thank you I just walked on the end of
your explanation so if this is an
ignorant question then I apologize but I
believe what I just heard you say is
that you wouldn't support this bill
because it might increase the lot you
might need an increase in lot size and
removes the town's ability to to require
an
increase is that the question was what
the difference right um with this bill
and as I said to representative Dumont
part of what this bill takes out is a
municipal municipalities ability um
allow accessory um sorry detached
accessory dwelling units if in judging
whether it needs an additional lot a
bigger lot size it has that ability to
do that in current in the current
legislation in front of you that delete
deletes that repeals that portion um the
nhma believes that local control is
important for a number of reasons
infrastructure issues um stress on
infrastructure um health and safety with
you know sewage capacity and water
capacity um as well as
um that was it I'm sorry lost my train
of thought no that's fine I was
clarifying because I wanted to ask a
question may asked the question follow
you followup thank you um so my
understanding of the current law from
2017 is actually while there may be an
ability for a town to require a larger
lot size for say something that they're
not having to approve like a detached or
a second ad
there is no current law that you
actually can build an Adu the town can
limit other things like parking lot
requirements or parking space
requirements but there's no ability in
our current law as I understand it um
for a town to require a certain lot size
on an attached Adu and I guess my
question is why would you need a larger
lot for a detached versus an an
attached unless you want me I I'm gonna
I'm going to actually turn it over to my
associate Brody he he actually may know
the answer thank
you if that's okay with the chair yes
state your name for the record please uh
my name is bires I represent the Amire
Municipal Association um let me crack
open my
notes so your question was in regards to
why would we treat a essentially why
would we treat a detached Adu separately
from an attached Adu correct
specifically why if the Adu is the same
size why would you need a bigger lot
size for a detached versus attached
because a detach could as long as it um
conforms to the requirements of the
Planning and Zoning is not next to the
dwelling unit I mean you may need more
space um you also may need additional
lot size for sewage disposal and um
health and safety of the community so um
I mean our position is that um and then
there's also Conformity to
municipalities have an interest in
um in the integrity and the character of
neighborhoods and how they look and so
um an attached Adu obviously I mean
they're very different in nature while
they Ser Sim while they serve similar
purposes um detach you know having a
separate dwelling unit essentially a
second you know what would be like a
second um Abode on your property um it
may require a additional um it may
require additional space and then there
are some things that the bill doesn't
consider for example um like ledge or
other things that might be on the lot
that really limit the building envelope
so if you don't require maybe additional
acreage um you know you could have a
1acre lot with an existing unit and then
all of a sudden you could find out that
3/4 of the lot is ledge that isn't
really buildable um and that could
create other issues for how the density
looks further question you may inquire
thank you um so I hear the words you're
saying but I don't understand why you
would need the ability to set a larger
lot limit if it's ledge that's already
determined like whether or not you can
build in that space is already
determined so if it's ledge it's ledge
you can't build there right you can't
build it anyway um if it's what was the
other thing oh this like setbacks like
you need a larger lot because there's
not enough space well if there's not
enough space to build then there's not
space to build there anyway so why would
you need the ability if there's not
enough room on that lot given the
setbacks to build one then you can't
they can't build it anyway so why would
you need the ability to prohibit them
from building it except for on a larger
lot if they can't build it anyway and
the water and sewer doesn't make sense
to me because 500 square fet one bedroom
one
bathroom has the same requirements for
water and sewer as does whether it's
attached or detached so I I'm hearing
what you're saying and it doesn't make
sense why a town would need to have
extended abilities to set lot limits
when all those they wouldn't be able to
build it according to current law and
according to this bill anyway according
what you just
said um my reading of the bill is
different but that's okay representative
um you threw a lot out there what is
your specific question if I may
clarify so my specific question was um
originally why why would a town need to
set a a larger lot limit on an attach a
detach and I realize I'm answering the
the the person testifying his question
um why would a town need the ability to
set a larger lot limit on a detached
versus an attach which they currently
don't have the ability to I heard a
bunch of answers that didn't actually
make any sense and I was giving you the
opportunity to make sense of those
answers based on what I responded with
so if if you just want to leave it as
you read it differently then that's fine
we can leave it
there than there any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you is there anybody else in the room
that would like to testify in HP 577
right hello again um so my name is Chris
Freeman uh I am the owner and executive
manager of belt Howard Property
Management I hold an inactive real
estate license in the state of New
Hampshire and I sit on two work groups
with the badok resource Alliance which
is a multi sector Coalition focused on
housing affordability uh as I've
disclaimed in the past I'm representing
my own views and not the views of the
MRA although I don't think anybody in
the group uh would object to me saying
that they're very in favor of adus uh
one of the the work groups that I'm
involved with there is uh specifically
focused on Adu education uh we have an
event coming up to kind of educate the
population of uh the madok region on uh
their options there uh so there's a lot
of reasons to be in favor of adus um I
think several other people have already
spoken to the multigenerational benefits
um there's also pretty significant
financial benefits uh in including um
the the ability to age in place uh which
supports multigeneration as well as uh
the needs of the elderly population um
but also for young people uh who are
purchasing their first home uh as I
bought my first home when I was 26 and
um the ability to rent out extra space
in that home made just a huge difference
in my ability to uh build a financial
base and continue to exist in a state
where the cost of housing is continually
Rising uh and at this point um I own
eight properties in New Hampshire I
don't own any single family properties
uh they they're Money Pit um and uh even
my own primary residence we have an Adu
in the basement that covers the property
taxes um just kind of pulling out my
financial calculator here if you picture
somebody who who you know purchases
their first home at the age of 30 they
have about 35 years before they reach
retirement age and if they were getting
$1,500 a month not adjusted for
inflation uh and they were putting that
into their uh 401K uh because they've
now freed up some of their housing
expense they'd be looking at a
retirement Nest Egg of $2.7 million and
with a safe withdrawal rate of 4% that's
a six figure income that is the
difference between an uncomfortable
retirement on you know the the median
social security benefit is around $1900
a month and a very comfortable uh
retirement so I see this as a great
opportunity to set people up for success
in the future um you know people who are
going to rented out on a short-term
basis um as as the uh woman from
Peterboro mentioned um you do need that
in order to get over the high cost of
construction upfront I I don't see the
increase in short-term rentals is being
fundamentally detrimental uh if anything
it's going to lower rates in the
short-term housing market and make it
less of a viable alternative uh and so I
think you know that would create some
Market pressures for people to convert
their short-term rentals into more
traditional housing um but it's you know
you're going to find that equilibrium
point so uh that's all I have to say on
that bill
thank you there any questions seeing
none thank you very
much Brian you had something you wanted
to
add thank you for allowing me to come
back up a second time I'll be really
really brief um I noticed on bullet
point number 26 uh and I've seen this
where um some communities will actually
have this
uh and I think that this is important
because what this bill does is it takes
it out it's a municipality shall not
require a familiar a f a family
relationship between the occupants of an
accessory dwelling unit and the
occupants of a uh principal dwelling
unit so some of these some of these the
language in some towns not my
town uh are not going to allow an Adu
unless it's a family member I don't know
how you police that number one but more
importantly what this bill does is puts
a stop to that because it is out there
so I just wanted to point that out
because I didn't hear anything um
discussed about that representative Reed
thank you Mr chair so that's actually
current law the bill as written because
there were enough changes it's not doing
the strike and the Bold it's just saying
this entire section is going to be
replaced but I would say about 90% is
actually in current law it's just a few
little tweaks but that is currently in
law you are correct there are some
municipalities who have illegally put
into their zoning practices restrictions
on and I've pointed it out in this very
committee last year um if they enforce
those ordinances then they could be sued
they're putting them indeed restrictions
and I don't think it's right and it's
not going to solve the problem that we
all want to address is the affordability
of housing especially for the elderly or
the younger family so thank you very
much thank you is there anybody else
would like to testify on
577 all right I'll close the hearing
can just recess to
11 recess it to 11 yeah we'll recess to
11: thank
you
e
e e
okay we'll open the public hearing for
HB
685 chair recognizes representative Joe
Alexander thank you Mr chair members of
the House housing for the record my name
is Joe Alexander I represent the town of
gtown um I'm here today to introduce HP
685 a critical piece of legislation
designed to empower private property
owners and support the growth of
affordable housing options throughout
New Hampshire as we all know New
Hampshire is facing a severe housing
crisis with riseing cross and growing
demand for affordable living spaces in
this context one of the most important
rights we can protect and expand is the
right of property owners to use their
land how they see fit within the bounds
of reasonable public regulation HB 685
is designed to support these public
these private property rights while also
addressing the housing shortage at its
core HB 685 provides a clear path
forward for manufactured housing to be
allowed in all residentially zoned areas
across New Hampshire by doing so it
ensures property owners have the right
to utilize their land for manufactured
housing without unnecessary restrictions
or local ordinances that may prevent
such use section one of HP 685 amends
RSA
67431 to clarify the definition of
manufactured housing this definition
includes homes that are built on
permanent chassis designed to be used as
a dwelling and connected to essential
utilities like Plumbing Heating and
electrical systems it's important to
note that this bill specifically
excludes Campers or recreational
vehicles ensuring that we are focusing
on permanent residential solutions that
will stand the test of time section two
is the heart of this bill it mandates
that manufactured housing be PR be
permitted in all residential zones with
every municipality in New Hampshire this
is a strong protection for private
property rights of individuals that wish
to place these homes on their land it
ensures that no municipality can
restrict or prohibit the use of the
housing in in residential
areas um allowing the property owner the
discretion further section two requires
Municipal zoning ordinances be amended
to comply with the statute eliminating
local restrictions that may otherwise
unfairly limit or discriminate against
manufactured housing
Property Owners should have the freedom
to develop their
land section three establishes a
six-month timeline to amend their zoning
ordinances ensuring that we act swiftly
on local reg regulations with this new
policy Additionally the Department of
Housing and Urban Development will
oversee compliance provide
municipalities with support and guidance
they need I believe there's an amendment
floating around by representative Paige
um that would move the timeline out to
comply with this section I'm I'm totally
in support of that amendment by passing
85 will expand property rights increase
housing options Empower individuals and
families across New Hampshire and just
to put in perspective I represent um a
town of gtown that has a very beautiful
manufacturing house co-op in town um
called medville cooperative and um you
know there's different processes in
which they could um establish their own
co-ops but I think what's important is I
get calls from Granite Staters across
the state because of this bill and
another bill that was signed into law
last year about hey I want to I bought a
huge property I want to build a bunch of
manufactured housing on this property so
my family can live together in a
compound I get those calls all the time
local ordinances prohibit this sort of
thing from happening unless they get in
a co-op this is totally going to free up
that right for them to do that um
provided they follow um water sewer
standards things like that but um I
think this is a step in the right
direction I think we need a lot more
small houses across the state and
manufactured housing is one of the key
pieces of puzzle so I'm happy to answer
questions there's people here hopefully
to speak in support thank you we have
any questions representative Reed thank
you Mr chair thank you representative
for putting in this bill and adding me
as a co-sponsor I am in support um I do
notice that the language specifically
exempts modular and other um pre-site
built pre-fabricated housing and I was
wondering why do that instead of include
that type of housing I'm not talking
about RVs or Campers or anything without
a foundation um but why not include
other um non-stick built housing uh in
this to allow as many options as
possible for someone to be able to buy a
piece of land and put up something
affordable that is safe specifically um
in this is language that was discussed
in this committee last term um as long
as it meets state and federal building
code um why not expand not just
manufactured housing but quanset prefab
modular all of those well thank you very
much for the question and thank you
again for being a co-sponsor on this
bill um I will confer with the chair of
the committee but I believe that this
can have a work session next week where
I believe the committee can discuss more
about this I'm certainly open to
it dick daxon
representative Alexander I have a
question about section
five uh it says the Department of
Housing and Urban Development shall
oversee and ensure compliance with this
statute providing guidance and support
to municipalities as needed to my
knowledge the state of New Hampshire
doesn't have a Department of Housing and
urbanville did I miss something no you
didn't miss something I'm totally
willing to scratch that okay sentence
out and and that I would if that would
be my that's my only concern with the
bill uh just cuz on the being on the
receiving end of this legislation I may
wind up in a town where they say well
you need to get approval from the
Department of Housing and Urban
Development who says to me who are you
and why are you calling us well
hopefully it functions a little more
effectively now but I wouldn't want to
call the feds for this well my point is
dealing on the local planning board
level they may use this you may have
this wonderful Bill and it may all work
fine and then they're going to say up
you got to check that box you can't do
it so that's my concern with
that representative Aron thank you for
bringing this bill forward I my question
is how would this affect the building of
trailer parks which are not allowed in
certain municipalities well this I mean
so a key piece to this legislation is
the this enables manufactured housing
this is different than a trailer Park
Model and it and I think the key piece
is the permanent chassis component where
it's something where it's a permanent
stable housing option and typically when
you find trailer parks they're more
mobile um can be you know moved from
town to town things like that so this is
a more stable housing option so they're
not
related and I think that's part of the
conversation is is letting the public
know that there's a separation there's
no there's not a relation
there representative Reed thank you Mr
chair and I'm just asking because I'm
struggling to understand this so are we
def the question was regarding trailer
parks are we defining trailer parks in
the traditional kind of colloquial use
which is a manufactured housing Park
which is these would be the same type of
units or are we talking about like RV
camper Parks um and which this would not
address whatsoever um and
then further if the concern is that this
would allow the creation of subdivisions
of manufactured
housing um then then would it not be
prudent to put in something along the
lines of for a um owner occupied lot for
example they can buy their own and that
an a manufactured house can substitute
for an Adu for example or any other
thing that's
allowed uh stick built allowed in the
town you can substitute a manufactured
house
um but not the creation of a subdivision
of manufactured housing if that's my
understanding of the original intent of
the question yeah I thank you for the
question I don't think that any of that
language is required because if this
bill goes through if you're in a
residentially zoned area and you want to
build a manufactured house provided you
follow you know the typical requirements
a planning board goes through um setback
requirements water sewer infrastructure
things like that you should be allowed
to build it so um the same process would
happen under a subdivision as you would
go through that sort of process as
well are there any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you chair calls Abby
Bronson good morning chairman and
members of the committee um my name's
Abby Bronson I am a born and raised
Granite stator I currently live in
Manchester ward 3 but I'm here today as
the Director of policy and advocacy for
the New Hampshire Community Loan Fund uh
the New Hampshire Community Loan Fund as
you might know is a nonprofit lender um
primarily what we do is we help
residents in manufactured home
communities purchase their parks to
become resident-owned but we also um
provide Fair fixed rate 30-year
mortgages for manufactured housing um
I'm here in strong support of HP 685 um
and we appreciate representative
Alexander for bringing this bill forward
um we support it because we believe
it'll help more New Hampshire families
achieve the American dream of home
ownership um rep Alexander said it and
you'll probably hear it every day in
this committee um we're in a housing
Supply and affordability crisis um and
we have to use every tool available to
address it um this bill would create one
such very important tool um and will put
home ownership within reach as I said um
and just increase the supply of housing
which we all know we desperately need um
so when in an environment where the
median cost of a single family home is
skyrocketed U manufactured homes
represent an affordable option in fact
right now in most um of our
resident-owned communities you can own a
manufactured home for less than renting
a an apartment of the same size um this
won't be the case if we don't make it
easier to place new manufactured housing
units as is done in six HP
685 um as representative Alexander
mentioned it would allow manufactured
housing by right and res entally zoned
areas um and it'll just make it more
accessible for younger families to
purchase their first home and older
Granite Staters to downs siiz we heard a
lot um in for the last bill um about the
importance of multigenerational living
manufactured housing also creates and
provides a lot of that um I also would
be remiss not to note manufactured homes
are not only affordable they're safe and
dignified housing they're on par with
site-built homes in terms of durability
and safety allowing them all residential
areas will not only serve to benefit
will only serve to benefit the cities
and towns across the state because they
desperately need housing for their
workers so I urge you to vote a to pass
on HP 685 thank you thank you there any
questions seeing none thank you very
much IV van I said it right this time
thank you all for letting me talk again
I'm Ivy van I'm a land Ed planner in the
state of New Hampshire and I'm here to
support this bill uh manufactured
housing is not your Granddaddy's hunting
camp anymore manufactured housing units
are attractive safe they appreciate like
a regular house they no longer
depreciate like cars which they did in
the past they're built to strict
standards they ought to be treated like
any other form of housing as a planner
I'm particularly interested in the
possibility of being able to use
manufactured housing units in what are
called um Cottage courts which is a
small grouping of cottages on a single
lot with shared systems shared water and
septic systems or water and sewer if you
have that well in septic otherwise those
are ways where people can live more
inexpensively in community and
manufactured housing is a great use um
in those those um clusters of housing so
I'd like to urge the committee to
support this bill and thank you all
again thank you there any questions
seeing none thank
you Sarah Holland
good morning thank you so much um my
name is Sarah Holland I am a real estate
broker in central New Hampshire and I am
the 2025 chair of the public policy
committee for the New Hampshire
Association of Realtors and the Realtors
ask for your support on HB
685 manufactured housing is a critical
component in New Hampshire's housing
landscape making up about 10% of
residential sales in 2024 so just last
year it is also a more affordable option
for for many New Hampshire residents
with a median sale price of
$162,000 opposed to as opposed to the
$514,000 median sale price for a single
family home currently in the state it's
also worth noting that manufactured
housing prices are increasing faster
than single family homes since 2019 the
median priced single family home
increased 71% while the manufactured
homes have increased by 138 8% going
from 68,000 to
162,000 the interest and demand for such
housing is only increasing as a
costeffective solution to the inventory
shortage government regulations largely
local Municipal zoning ordinances have
been used to prevent the mar the private
Market from meeting the demand of such
housing this bill is a long overdue fix
for that towns opposed manufactured
housing out of a bias against more
affordable housing options believing it
will alter the character of the
neighborhood it is an outdated notion of
what manufactured housing looks like
today today's manufactured homes often
resemble traditional homes blending
seamlessly into neighborhoods often
having foundations with basements and
garages while maintaining high quality
living conditions as you previously have
heard and we need to remember this is
not the government's land this is
private property as long as a
community's health and safety are
protected then the government should
always tread very lightly on mandating
what you or I can do with our properties
RSA
67416 States very specifically that the
intent of zoning in New Hampshire is for
the purpose of promoting the health
safety or the general welfare of the
community the argument I just don't like
that sort of housing is not a health
safety or general welfare argument
zoning in New Hampshire has veered quite
a distance from its original intent of
separating incompatible land uses
the residential use of a home is still
the residential use of a home regardless
of how much it costs to construct or how
big that home might be if you're in
favor of growing New Hampshire's economy
then pass this bill since this is how
our Workforce which is our businesses
which our businesses desperately need
will find more affordable housing if
you're in favor of ensuring New
Hampshire R retirees find a more
reasonable home to enjoy their
retirement then support this bill this
is how they can downsize and live on
fixed income if you want to protect
private proper property rights please
also support this bill we ask you to
support HB 685 thank you for your time
and I'm happy to answer any questions
thank you there any questions to the
committee representative buer thank you
Mr chairman um uh did I hear you uh
correctly that you said that the median
sale price on manufactured housing is
162,000 yes wow that is that is
substantially less um does that is that
for that figure does that also include
manufactured housing where the land
underneath is leased so there is a wide
range as far as pricing goes um for
homes for that specific reason whether
they're in a community in which that
land is rented um which you do have to
factor in that homeowner cost of paying
that lot rent um and then Properties or
manufactured homes on their own land so
it is a wide wide
range representative
Reed thank you just to clarify what was
just brought up I believe that median
cost is just the manufactured house
irrespective of where it's going to go
and I know this from checking out the
prices there are plenty in the 200,000
up to $300,000 figures um very nice
places that I think anybody here would
be extremely happy to live um so is that
correct it's regardless of the so it is
the median purchase price of a
manufactured home so that takes into
account those that are being sold on
rented lot space and those that are on
private land it's the median of that but
there's some that are sold that I
apologize follow up sure the question
you may inquire uh there are some most
well most of the time when people buy
new ones they are buying it from a
dealer not on so they have a piece of
land they are separately purchasing just
the manufactured house yeah and that is
not part of our data because we're
generally not a part of that process
only once it's already located on a
piece of property are there any other
questions seeing none thank you
Nick
Taylor thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee I'm Nick Taylor I'm the
director of housing action New Hampshire
still a Statewide organization that
advocates for pro housing policies we
are here in support of House Bill 685 um
the housing affordability conversation
often focuses on rental units this is a
great opportunity for home ownership
below the median sales price which has
been persistently up above 500,000 in
recent quarters so this is a real great
opportunity to expand affordable home
ownership we Echo the property rights
and health and safety um conversations
that have been brought forward by other
speakers and also say to the question of
the definitions we really appreciate the
um interest in some of the other
Innovative construction models around 3D
printing and prefab our understanding is
that at least in this bill those are
just in relation to the definition
section not in terms of being prohibited
on existing lands We Have You Know
spoken with companies that are doing 3D
printing homes in New Hampshire that are
not running into these prohibitions
already right and so it may be pertinent
and relevant for the committee to think
about making sure that that's not
something that could come forward but as
of now that is not something that a
community is prohibiting in terms of the
other types of construction to our
knowledge so um again we really we full
support there's no reason to treat these
any differently than any other type of
construction it's all rooted in stigma
in our opinion and so we again
appreciate the committee and hope you
look favorably upon this Bill thank you
there are any questions seeing none
thank you very
much Brody
deales hi for the record uh Brody Dees I
represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Association um and we are opposed to
House Bill 685
um we believe that local decisions are
best made by um local residents and the
voting booth um we think that planning
boards uh can um best make decisions to
represent their their constituents and
residents and to propose uh zoning
amendments and planning amendments to
the um to the local ordinances that bet
best meet the municipality's needs um I
think our our biggest concern with this
bill is specifically in section 2 Roman
3 where it says no municipality shall
adopt or enforce any Zing ordinances
regulation or policy that discriminates
against manufactured housing by
prohibiting or unreasonably restricting
its placement in residential zones we
find that to be very Broad and open and
maybe tough for interpretation for
municipalities that want to adopt
reasonable zoning or planning
requirements for a manufactured home um
so that is our biggest concern is having
that unclarity for local planning boards
zoning boards and um others who help in
the uh planning department Department of
the municipality and um with that I will
um take any questions thank you Mr
chairman or Mr Vice chairman thank you
there any questions representative Paige
thank you Mr chair um so I look I look
pretty favorably upon this bill um and I
Echo a lot of the um comments earlier
about a lot of this being rooted in
stigma um but I also want to be
responsive to what I just heard from you
uh
about that Roman numeral 3 so my
question for you is sort of what what
reasonable restrictions would
nhma like articulated here you know I'm
I'm trying to think what those
reasonable restrictions might be and if
you have guidance for us on what you
want to see this to be a fixed property
which I know can be tough with
manufactured housing because you're
going to want to put that in a slab and
you're going to want it to be movable
but um you know having a fixed having it
be in a fixed real property I think is
an important aspect I think design
aspects are important to municipality
especially a residential neighborhood um
you're going to want it to meet the
planning um design requirements uh
depending on the situation um so I think
those are just two off the top of my
head that I can think of where there is
a compelling Community interests to make
sure that the type of manufactured home
and how it looks and ensuring that's
it's a fixed real property that it
actually stays there and someone isn't
just going to put a slab and then
eventually decide well I'm going to move
to a neighboring municipality and leave
the slab in the empty lot there um I
think that's important so I think those
are two things that I can think of that
municipalities would probably look to
guidance for us and some may argue is
that a reasonable or unreasonable well
when we use terms like that in the
statute and don't Define them or don't
point to some other statute that has
good definitions then um then what ends
up happening is municipalities they're
using their discretion to the best of
their ability to listen to their
residents and then you have people who
are trying to develop and utilize this
uh statute who are going to say well
from my opinion that's unreasonable from
the municipality's re uh vantage point
it might be very reasonable and it might
be even extremely reasonable to the rest
of the residents that adopted specific
planning ordinances or zoning ordinances
in the
municipality there any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you is there anybody else that would
like to testify on HB
685 yes come on up
all right uh hello again uh Chris
Freeman and I am here to testify in
favor of House Bill 685 um in addition
to expanding and affirming the property
rights of land owners uh as others have
mentioned it also does create a more
accessible Bottom Rung on the lad for
home ownership uh with prices in the sub
$200,000 range um the the gentleman from
from Peterboro raised the cottage courts
I would raise that as a potential area
if you do take this back to Workshop
that you um consider contacting some
stakeholders from the different
municipalities I know Keen New Hampshire
has recently um adopted a cottage core
ordinance and reading through it um as
is the tendency of that planning board
it's somewhat prescriptive and I would
just want to make sure that when we're
thinking about the ways that
municipalities are adopting Cottage core
ordinances and the way that this um
proposal could be implemented at the
state level that we don't create any
ambiguities or conflicts um that would
preempt uh you know Developers in uh the
different towns from being able to make
sense of uh what their options are uh
where we could end up confounding
property rights um but uh generally
speaking um I think we just heard that
there's concerns about U maybe the
Aesthetics people have talked about the
stigma associated with these uh first of
all if you can build a split level you
should be able to build what's basically
a
ranch um but uh you know some of the
concerns around uh where these might be
built you know and am I you know a
doctor in Handover concerned about uh
you know a trailer moving in across the
street from my10 million estate chances
are the buyer who's going to be
purchasing that land is not going to be
building a uh a manufactured home um the
market forces do tend to equalize uh the
types of construction that people choose
to develop in different areas
um uh so so there is that um but in in
general neighborhoods uh there is
evidence that socioeconomic diversity is
a really strong engine of upward
Mobility um you know if you are somebody
who is just getting started and and and
you know building your uh Financial base
and you live in a neighborhood where
there are people who are further along
in that Journey than you it does open
doors uh for you to be able
to start a small business maybe your
neighbor is going to loan you money
towards your startup um you know
certainly being able to borrow against
the equity in your home uh you know
strongly advances those goals um so all
around I see this as as pretty strongly
uh beneficial uh and that is all oh
actually one one other point um when we
do Place restrictions on uh on mobile
homes uh based on stigma um you know we
have we have
this this tendency of planning boards to
try to preserve the existing character
of of neighborhoods because they want to
support higher property values and the
problem with that is that if you are
using state power to support
individual's property values what you're
really doing is you're upwardly
redistributing wealth and I think that
that's really an unethical uh violation
of the the property rights of wouldbe
homeowners and that's all I have thank
you are there any
questions seeing none thank you very
much is there anybody else that like to
testify okay I'll close the hearing on
685 turn the gavel back over to the
chairman of housing
okay so um given the questions asked
about the first two bills we're going to
take those to work sessions next Tuesday
I'll publish that in the calendar um we
don't have any hearings next Tuesday so
next Tuesday will just be for us to work
through the language of um some of these
bills
um at this time we don't have a full
committee so I don't want to exact um
some bills that uh we may we may not
agree on but I do think I have one bill
that I'd like to exec and then we can go
to lunch um that
is
um House Bill
604 and
I I confir with the ranking member
you're good with this y okay
um so at this point I'll call on
representative Aaron to make a motion on
House Bill
604 thank you Mr chair I move that we
retain this bill to work on it uh in the
future because there's some language in
here that's not quite clear I second
okay so move by representative Aaron
second by representative Reed to retain
HP 604 comments on
this I I think there's some Merit to it
and I think that um I'd like to hash out
some of the details I think maybe
building a revolving fund or something
and putting a dollar in it would be more
value I don't really love the provision
about the workforce housing range that
there is so I'd like to kind of work on
it and see and I think this maybe we
could come to a bipartison agreement on
it
so all right um are you
ready represent page I was I was just
going to say I agree and I think um some
of the comments today on the other Adu
Bill we were hearing this morning really
get at that the heart of that
affordability question and I applaud the
sponsor for trying to find solutions to
try to make this pencil um for folks who
want to put in adus um because I you
know if we're passing this Adu bill that
we heard this morning we also want to
make sure that we have um that we have
those solutions for folks so that they
can actually afford to put them in so I
think they go hand inand and I'm happy
to retain it
all right you ready y okay the Kirk will
call the
roll Vice chairman Cole
yes representative Faxton yes
representative Aaron yes representative
Buu yes representative Dumont yes
representative Grant yes representative
miles representative Miner yes
clerk reinford yes representative Paige
yes representative
boras representative Reed yes
representative
Gibbs representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative hegner
yes representative Kerwin
yes chairman Alexander yes
so the vote was uh 15 to zero that
motion carries um so at this point we
don't have a full committee I don't want
to pull up any more exec sessions so uh
we have a a rather lengthy lengthy lunch
um I do believe representative Cole has
to introduce a bill at 1:00 in another
committee so because there's I can't I
can't share my own bill I'm going to
recess until 1:15 and we'll hear how
spill 459 at that time okay so we are at
lunch thank you
everyone
e
e e
good afternoon it's 1:00 committee on
housing I'm going to open the public
hearing on HB 459 and recess the public
hearing to um 115 thank
you
e
e e
okay we open the Committee hearing on
hb45 59 and repres representative Joe
Xander um thank you Mr chair members of
the committee this is the last time you
hear from me today in this position and
bear with me this is probably my longest
set of remarks um and as we know I'm
here to introduce HB
459 as we know the housing crisis in New
Hampshire is urgent and the time for
Meaningful action is now for years we've
seen skyrocketing housing costs that put
homeownership Out Of Reach for too many
hardworking Grant Staters from young
families to essential workers the
inability to find affordable housing has
had a profound impact on our economy and
our
communities let me Begin by explaining
where I come from I'm a full-time
Bartender by trade as you may or may not
know it can be a pretty lucrative trade
and you can live a comfortable life
however being in the hospitality
industry does not make you a rich person
unless you open your own place it does
however allow you to live comfortably
under our current system Grand estaters
like myself do not have the same
opportunity to own property partly due
to unreasonable lot
sizes hb4 59 addresses the most
significant obstacles to affordable
housing in our state restrictive minimum
lot size requirements that unnecessarily
inflate the cost of building new homes
for too long regulations have demanded
large lot sizes that make it impossible
for small or more affordable homes these
restrictions have often been used to
enforce snob zoning a term used to
describe zoning practices that
deliberately limit access to housing in
certain communities by pricing out
working families and people of modest
means let's call it what it is it's snob
zoning it's about keeping people out and
it's been a tactic used in our
municipalities to preserve the status
quo and exclude those who can't afford
to buy into the existing system these
zoning laws often reflect a desire to
protect the interest of those who
already own property and they aim to
keep the wrong type of people from
moving in it's not about preserving the
environment it's not about Community
Aesthetics it's about
exclusion in my opinion teachers
firefighters police officers bartenders
Amazon Prime delivery drivers are not
the wrong type of people but
unfortunately under our current system
people are zoned out of communities HB
459 is a direct response to this
thinking this bill would require
municipalities eliminate unreasonable
minimum lot sizes for single family
residential homes particularly when it
comes to those lots that aren't
connected to Municipal sewer systems
under HP 459 municipalities can no
longer impose lot sizes that are
excessively large without showing
evidence that it's truly necessary for
the community's health or safety
specifically HP 459 proposes that in
areas without Municipal um or Community
sewer systems no or ordance can require
a single family lot larger than what is
necessary to accommodate an individual
sewer Disposal system as defined by Dees
for lot served by municipal or Community
sewer infrastructure the bill limits the
minimum lot size to 22,000 Square ft for
the committee's reference that's about
half an acre unless the town can provide
solid evidence that a larger lot size is
needed for public health or
safety this bill would make it easier
for developers to build homes that are
affordable and available to those who
need them by limiting unnecessary
restrictions on law sizes we'll see the
creation of smaller more costeffective
homes that will ultimately lead to lower
housing
prices let me be clear this is not about
forcing municipalities to abandoned
zoning regulations entirely it's about
striking a balance between local control
and ensuring that we can build the homes
we need to keep up with demand local
governments still have the ability to
make other zoning decisions as long as
they don't involve excessive lotsize
requirements that price people out of
the
market my friends from the new New
Hampshire Municipal Association will no
doubt come out against this bill which
is fine I hope the committee members
will be shed enough to ask and HMA why
they believe municipalities should have
the right to set minimum lot sizes that
far outpace what is necessary for the
health and safety of the community who
is being
excluded this bill is about property
rights it's about allowing people to
build homes on affordable appropriately
sized Lots without being subject to
arbitrary excessive regulations that
only serve to make housing more
expensive and Out Of Reach for too many
people and by the way line four of this
bill says in a majority of land Zone to
permit single family residential uses so
I read that as
51% so the other 49% of the Town set
whatever standards you want we're saying
51% minimum LW size under this
bill the impacts of these policies are
real families arable to find starter
homes businesses are struggling to find
workers who can afford to live nearby
and our local communities are seeing
fewer and fewer opportunities for
economic growth if we are serious about
addressing this crisis and we must be
then HP 459 is a crucial step in the
right direction I urge you consider the
long-term effects of restrictive snob
zoning policies it created the crisis
we're in now let's not close the door
behind us let's pass HB 459 open the
door greater opportunity for all thank
you thank you there any questions from
the committee representative
Gibbs thank you Mr
chair um and thank you representative
Alexander um on the whole this is a very
good bill um and I support it and I
strongly agree with uh your testimony um
I have one problem uh which is the basis
of my question um and that has to do
with lots serviced by municipal or
Community sewer
infrastructure um a lot of those lots
probably most of them will be in urban
areas and um the um minimum lot size
allowed uh for that is 22,000 Square ft
which as you mentioned comes out to
about half an acre uh uh a lot of the
houses that are already in such
neighborhoods will be on Lots smaller
than half an acre think of an urban um
area in Manchester in ashaa even in
conquer uh a lot of the lots of single
family houses will be smaller than half
an acre so why shouldn't that um minimum
lot size that's allowed be not half an
acre but a quarter of an acre um
representative Gibbs thank you very much
for your question I think there may be
members of the committee that agree with
you and I I have not evaluated that yet
so I can't take a position but to answer
your question line 17 section three of
this bill says the requirements in
paragraphs 1 and two shall not be
construed to limit the pro potential for
development on Lots created prior to
July 1st 2025 meaning those smaller lots
that already
exist there's nothing preventing that
that those from continuing to be
developed as
needed sorry followup follow up May
inquire thank you um and that's I
understand that and that's um that's a
good exception um and obviously uh it
all always has to be in line with what
the sewer the local sewer system will
support and I agree with that entirely
but say if someone buys a larger lot and
wants to split it up into quarter of an
acre lots why shouldn't we allow
that I I wholeheartedly agree I think
it's a property rights issue and um you
know I I take a look at legislative
approaches my legislative philosophy is
I'd rather take smaller bites of an
apple and get get what I we can get then
completely like eat the whole Apple at
once and um so while I may agree with
you personally I think this is a a a
modest approach to address the issue
that we have right
now representative thanks
D maybe I miss misunderstood the
bill coming off of Representative Gibb's
question my understanding of and I only
read it online just a few seconds ago uh
my understanding of the bill was that
what we were doing here was setting a
22,000 square foot maximum lot size that
could be required in those areas am I
reading that
backwards my my idea was that you
couldn't maximum yes Max you could you
couldn't require greater than 22 so you
could I use the wrong word you're right
okay so then if if that's the case then
I'm that just make sure I got it so it
makes all the difference in the world
okay representative
deont do you believe Frontage
requirements also pose the same issue
and how do you feel that would tie in
with this I'm I'm okay entertaining
something to deal with Frontage
requirements as well if that's what the
committee
desires yes representative um along
those lines how do you see the is
playing out in rural areas and and all
by that I'll bring up what do you think
this would look like in a conservation
subdivision um well I I just go back to
the line four of the bill that
allows it to be zoned in a majority but
not all land so I think that that would
help cover some a situation like
that any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
chair now call on Chris
Norwood good good afternoon Mr chair
members of the committee my name is
Chris Norwood and uh I have a handout
that I'll leave you all with of just a
Q&A that we've prepared so my name is
Chris Norwood I'm a real estate broker
with a firm at nii Norwood group I
reside in the Sea Coast and I am the
2025 Vice chair of the New Hampshire
Association ation of Realtors public
policy committee and our some 7,000
members would encourage you to support
this bill um shortly in one word it's
density uh density is really the key in
order for us to build more affordably
and we feel that this bill uh in the in
the words of Representative Alexander
makes a it's a good modest step towards
increasing that density um a couple
things I'll just leave you with that are
you know my personal experience with lot
development and density when I first
became a broker in my early 20s I kind
of thought naively that uh you know you
just take the the number of lot Allowed
by uh per acre and you kind of multiply
that by the number of Acres of the
parcel and then you have your your math
figured out that's how many single
family homes you can develop or how many
apartments you can put on a subject
parcel uh representative Dumont I
believe you brought up the the question
about Road Frontage right there's also
Wetland setbacks there's uh slopes right
there it's kind of like a game of 3D
chess which is why as a naive 20-some I
thought I could do this all and then you
really realize you do need a soil
scientist or a civil engineer to help
navigate it's not as simple as just
reading the zoning ordinance so I just
say that this is one piece of the puzzle
there are many other pieces of the
puzzle um and this is one piece of it I
I'll also say now 20 some odd years
later um I'm in the process of assisting
my parents with their home and figuring
out exactly what they should do with
their land and forgive you some context
they have 30 acres of land and their
original retirement goal was to build a
house a lot in the house in the back on
part of the 30 acres and then another
lot and a house on the back for my
brother and his sister-in-law um and
divide off the house that we grew up in
so essentially three lots on 30 Acres we
we couldn't do it we couldn't do it in
the zone that we were in without some
sub substantial variances and it had
nothing to do by the way with uh Road
Frontage it was all about lot size um so
I'm not here up for this bill because
it's going to make a material impact for
my parents my brother is no longer going
to build that house in the back nor are
my parents but I say that as an example
to illustrate that um sometimes what can
be perceived as a kind of right of
passage of a property owner to build on
their own property or to to bequeath
land to their children is unattainable
based upon today's current zoning laws
so finally there's just a couple things
that this bill there's a lot of good
things that this bill will do and
there's some misconceptions about this
bill I just want to clear them up it's
not going to mandate um you know those
maximum Lots you there are in the
plurality of land this bill applies to
so there's still 49% of the parcels that
you could have larger uh lot sizes if if
the municipality so chose also there's a
misconception I believe surrounding the
dees that uh because this is tied to
health and safety and soil that it would
increase the amount of labor for the
dees we've been in communication with
Dees currently before this bill we
believe there will be two touch points
when building a septic system on a
parcel with Dees after this bill we
believe there will be two touch points
for building that same septic system and
again some of that's outlined in these
Q&A
um so we thank you for the opportunity
to allow me to testify and happy to
answer any questions you may have thank
you are there any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you thank
you Mr
chair Ivy
van thank you Representatives thank you
for having me back no place I'd rather
be uh
I'm here to speak in favor of this bill
and I want to speak in favor of this
bill from a slightly different
perspective two slightly different
perspectives one of them is um the
question of the economic health of towns
one of the biggest um Town expenditures
every year is road maintenance uh I ran
the numbers five years ago 5 years ago
it cost
$465 to maintain one Centerline foot of
a town maintained road that numberers CL
is over $5 a foot now so when we have
large lot
sizes we are
increasing the amount that that road
should be supported by the town by the
by the house that faces it so so for
example if you have um a lot size that
requires 200 ft of Frontage somebody
over here asked about Frontage you're in
debting your town to for ,000 a year in
in road maintenance that house is not
paying that much road maintenance the
the road budget is usually about 10% of
the Town budget um I ran some numbers
years ago for a project that was on an
acre of land in town in Peterboro New
Hampshire it's a real place you can go
look at it uh it's a lot of one acre um
it ended up because it had water and
sewer it was able to have eight houses
on it we had an overlay that allowed
that when that parcel was
a um parking lot it paid no taxes belong
to the Catholic church it was valued at
$47,000 that parcel one of those houses
just
sold um just about a week ago for
$575,000 so that's a huge amount of tax
revenue coming into the town for no more
piping Plumbing plowing sanding or
ditching than there was when that was a
parking lot that's an economic win for
the town when we allow places to thicken
up like that we improve the economic
well-being of our town um reducing lot
sizes in places where there is sewer
infrastructure is a great way to do that
it's a really good way to do that and
it's very important for the E economy of
the town the other reason that I'm in
favor of this bill besides the obvious
one should we please have more housing
is that as an as a town planner I think
a lot about what kind of um a
streetscape are we are we creating and
when I talk about a streetscape I'm
talking about how does it feel to walk
down this street and when we have really
large Lots first of all you almost never
get sidewalks right because it's too
long it's too you know it doesn't work
so first of all now you got people
walking in the Street if they want to
walk things are farther apart it makes
it harder to make a place the AARP did a
survey I think it was three years ago
and ask people would they be willing to
live in a smaller house if they could
live in a walkable neighborhood with
amenities and by amenity means I mean a
small grocery store a neighborhood bar a
coffee shop things like that and 67% of
their respondents said they would
so having smaller Lots allows us to
create more of a neighborhood feel where
you can get those neighborhood amenities
where it is financially possible to put
in sidewalks so for those two reasons
the economic health of the town and the
social health of the people who live
there I would urge you to pass this Bill
thank you so much and I'm happy to take
any questions thank you there any
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much Jack
rudderman am I on yes uh good afternoon
Mr Vice chairman and members of the
committee my name is Jack rudderman uh I
am the legislative affairs advisor at
New Hampshire housing we are the state's
Housing Finance
Authority
uh just one
moment so uh appreciate the opportunity
to be here to testify today uh I am here
in support of HB 459 um as this
committee knows there is no single cause
of the acute housing crisis that our
state is
experiencing and unfortunately there is
no Silver Bullet to create enough Supply
to meet demand we have a huge shortfall
however we do know that one of the root
causes of the lack of affordable housing
is is local zoning restrictions in
particular zoning ordinances requiring
excessive minimum lot sizes for single
family homes if we are going to increase
the supply of new homes particularly
starter homes we need to start building
on smaller Lots we believe this bill
offers a reasonable means of boosting
the supply of affordable homes by
requiring lot sizing to be tied to
environmental standards already in place
for Lots not served by Municipal Water
uh and sewer systems and by also
establishing a limit on lot sizes for
homes on public water and sewer so uh a
lot of speakers have already made a lot
of great points about this bill I'm not
going to go on any further uh now uh and
um just would like to thank the
committee for uh your time and
consideration and um we would urge you
to support this Bill thank you thank you
there any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much Nick Taylor
good afternoon Mr Vice chairman and
members of the committee I'm Nick Taylor
the director of housing action New
Hampshire um we're a Statewide advocacy
organization that seeks to increase
access to housing and we are here in
support of this bill um as has been
mentioned large lot sizes often lead to
more expensive homes and make it harder
for folks to access home ownership
harder for the housing that is necessary
for our Workforce for our community so
many members of our towns large lot
sizes also lead to increased sprawl you
know New Hampshire is growing our
population is living longer and the
question is how are we going to develop
and when we require two three four acre
lots what we are saying is that we are
going to develop in a way that increases
sprawl and is bad for you know in many
respects the conservation and elements
of New Hampshire that so many folks love
um a couple points related to some
questions that came up earlier around
the conservation subdivision this
wouldn't overrule that in any way and in
all likelihood most conservation
subdivision ordinances already would
allow for smaller Lots so if you were
going to go that approach you would
probably continue to use your
municipalities conservation subdivision
same thing goes for the lot siiz
question around some of the urban areas
it's you know nothing in this would
require Manchester NASA conquered areas
where you already have those smaller
lots to to raise them you know and then
they would presumably keep the smaller
lot sizes that are already in ordinance
um and then there's also a Senate bill
that's attempting to do a similar thing
sponsored by Senator Murphy um and there
was some conversation around that same
question around Frontage and setbacks
and if you shrank the lot size but the
frontage and the setbacks were all in
place you could essentially render the
lot unbuildable and so you know I think
that's worth thinking about in terms of
you know some language that could say
nothing and this could allow a
municipality to render a lot unbuildable
based on additional um restrictions so
certainly a good point and things to
consider the final thing I will add is
that 58 communities in New Hampshire
already use some level of soil-based lot
sizing when they are determining um
residential zones and that's according
to Bea's land use survey for
municipality so this is not a New
Concept it is out there and it is being
used by municipalities right now so
thank you and happy to take any
questions thank you any questions from
the committee seeing none thank you very
much
NCH
GRE thank you Mr chair n gra uh for the
business and industry Association the
Statewide Chamber of Commerce we support
this legislation uh we are uh
particularly prioritizing legislation
that promotes density um this is one of
those bills um we uh we believe that
that's important based on what we've
heard from industry leaders about how we
can lower the cost of housing overall uh
I won't repeat anything already said
today uh I support all of that um one
thing I will add up I will add to the
discussion just because it's sometimes
becomes a
misconception um is the water and sewer
and well and septic process um so if you
are building a uh a new development
where you're putting in uh well uh and
septic unit you are already having to go
through the state uh Dees permitting
process this legislation would not
change that that um so if it is the case
that you cannot uh actually get a permit
for the lot at issue you are not getting
a permit and therefore you're not going
to be building because no one's going to
buy a house without water and sewer um
similarly on the uh Public Water and
Sewer side of things uh as you go
through that process and development uh
you have to contact the public uh water
and sewer
operator uh and actually go through
their process to make sure that they
have capacity so that's something they
already know as plant operators um and I
actually think there's actually a pretty
good example of how this all played out
in New London earlier this year uh there
were two uh side by side I believe it
was developments um I believe it was the
same developer 200 units uh and that
ended up stalling because it got
approval went through all the local
approval processes they were going to
put in a I believe first they the idea
was to connect it to the public water
system as it turned out New London did
not have capacity therefore that was
denied uh they then said well we'll put
in a well it turns out one of the sites
had some contamination from uh I believe
it's mtbe uh saw in the paper so again
that was denied um Dees is not going to
issue a permit for um poisoned water so
um that was denied and currently that
project is stalled so that just shows
how this would play out um um you know
were this legislation to pass it
wouldn't Force development where it's
not possible have to take any questions
that anybody has thank you any questions
from the committee see none thank you
very
much Meredith
Hatfield good afternoon I'm Meredith
Hatfield from The Nature Conservancy um
we don't have a position on this bill
but we wanted to share some thoughts
um we are kind of new to housing and we
are trying to figure out how we could be
helpful uh to the state addressing the
housing
crisis uh we've been working for about
60 years in New Hampshire to protect
land and water for people and for
animals um we're an employer a small
employer so we experience what a lot of
other employers do as well that it's
hard for people especially young people
to find a place to live in New Hampshire
uh we pride ourselves on Partnerships um
one that I love to talk about is our
partnership with New Hampshire do
helping uh with Culvert issues um we've
seen a lot of extreme weather lately uh
that has not only an impact on roads
Bridges and culverts but um from our
perspective it also really impacts
Wildlife and Fish so we've been able to
work with do to come up with uh Creative
Solutions including money um to try to
rebuild culverts so that they can uh
withstand more storms and also be better
for animal and fish Passage
um as representative Alexander said um
as he referred to snob zoning you know
we recognize that that often is not very
protective of the environment and that
it actually can cause sprawl uh habitat
fragmentation and perhaps other
unintended environmental consequences um
so I'm really just here to say that we
um we work already with a lot of the
folks supporting this bill um we're
looking to be a partner and to try to
figure out how we could
bring our science ific knowledge our
expertise and the significant mapping
that we've done of the state um showing
where important resources exist so that
we can try to figure out um where we
should be putting the housing that we
need thank you thank you there any
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you very
much Dave
Nelson thank you Mr chair my name is
Dave Nelson I'm appearing as an
individual um although I also have
served on the planning board in my U
Town for many years and I currently
serve as chair but this is my individual
contribution there have been a lot of um
wonderful um points made um and
obviously increasing density is going to
help make housing more affordable um my
only comment with respect to the
structure of this current Bild is it's
at least in the language seems to focus
extensively or almost exclusively on
septic designs um it is true that the an
HDs will permit a septic design of a
certain number of square feet from based
on the number of bathrooms and whatnot
in in the home but there's more to the
size of a lot than simply the area
reserved for subsurface um you know
Solid Waste Disposal um aquifers are one
of those things so sewage is important
water is is important um but outside of
a municipal water District we're talking
about aquafers um and that's not an
exact science um before the board we
have often heard people um suggest that
we should decline a um development
because anecdotally they have had
seasonal you know problems with their
well going dry and they want us to
guarantee that if we build more houses
it won't be a bigger problem and of
course we we can't say that so that's
one of those pieces of soft science that
that comes into the calculus
of determining um lot sizes is um
aquifers and and and water availability
um ledge obviously slopes uh wetlands
and so while I I plug the the intent to
review um some of the um lands use
sizing um I think it needs to consider a
bunch of other environmental factors um
besides just um septic systems I'll be
happy to take any
questions thank you representative Gibbs
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming to testify this this afternoon um
aren't there already limitations on
development that would affect
Wetlands yeah um there are and and
typically um depending on on the local
and state um there'll be a setback from
a a jurisdictional wet back land
there'll be a larger one from a prime
Wetland and of course that has to be
taken into account um in what is the
buildable um area of of a
lot are there any other
questions see none thank
you is there anybody else here that like
to testify on each come on up and just
pass your pink card along
up good afternoon Mr Vice chair members
of the committee uh my my name is Samuel
Hooper I'm leged of council with the
institute for justice we're a nonprofit
uh National civil liberties Law Firm
that Advocates among other things for
property rights so we do a lot of work
on zoning reform also on eminent domain
and some other issues like that we are
very strongly in support of this bill we
think it's excellent that New Hampshire
is um kind of being a national leader
when it comes to actually looking at how
we can tackle the housing crisis as
others have said and I won't repeat
there is no one Silver Bullet to
tackling the housing crisis there are
lots of IND individual reforms that need
to be made and it's important to not be
complacent you know having achieved one
thing whether that's reforming adus
minimum lot sizes mixed use development
that we take our eye off the ball and
other things but I think of the various
um reforms that we can make uh minimum
lot size reform is one of the most
important ones for the reasons that
others have said in terms of um having
greater density means that um
communities and um urbanism becomes more
sustainable for a town you're not having
to um spread um utilities road
maintenance and other things over a
smaller tax base you know just being
able to have that slight increase in
density can make a big difference
obviously at The Institute for justice
we approach syst of property rights
perspective as well and something was
said that really resonated with me in in
support of a previous bill um and and
the witness said you know this is not
the government's land and that's
something that we very much agree with
as well you know um there may be places
for you know restrictions on land use
they should in our opinion be connected
to nuisance you know if you're causing
actual nuisance in terms of noise um
abatement um pollution other issues to
your neighbors then there can be a place
for restrictions but if these
restrictions are arbitrary if they're
related to Aesthetics if they're related
to arbitrary minimum lot sizes that
aren't connected to a valid health and
safety reason then is our view at The
Institute for justice that there's
probably no place for those restrictions
um this bill I think Treads um a very
fair path you know allowing A reduced
minimum lot size for us for a bare
majority of the land and a municipality
but still allowing um you know the other
half or 49% of the land to retain those
larger sizes so we think that that's you
know a pragmatic Fair way to begin to do
this take an incremental reform that can
be beneficial I did want to note as well
I did notice um a fiscal note had been
attached to the bill I was curious about
it because it talked about an
indeterminate increase and it mentioned
the cost for municipalities in gathering
empirical evidence to contest the lot
size requirements I was a little
perplexed by this I I and I I may be
unfamiliar with the process here but it
seemed as though it was saying that
there would be a cost Association with
trying to subvert the purpose of the
bill um I'm based in Austin Texas I'm
more familiar with the Texas system
willough I testify around the country
but to me that wouldn't be a valid you
know reason to talk about you know this
is going to in cause cause additional
costs if the only costs are to subvert
what the purpose of the bill is to
contest the minimum lot size requirement
we think um as I say this bill is
excellent it's fair um it's pragmatic um
it will have benefits in terms of
increasing density um Financial
sustainability it will be good for
municipalities and it'll be good for
property rights as well which is our
priority at The Institute for justice um
with that thank you very much for
hearing me out I'm very happy to take
any questions thank you are there any
questions from the
committee see none thank you very much
is there anybody else would like to
testify yes come on up pass your ping
card along
please right uh good afternoon Chris
Freeman again um I'll keep my comments
short because a lot of what I had was
already covered by others but um one
thing uh when we think about development
and the impact of smaller lot sizes um
we look at other states that kind of R
stamp new developments that you have
these just acres and Acres of um
subdivisions uh one of the things that
that they have going for them that we
don't is they are flatland States and um
in New Hampshire we have a unique
challenge with uh the hilliness of the
terrain and the amount of wetlands that
we have and so when looking at this from
a conservation perspective being able to
take these kind of awkwardly shaped
spaces um in between the Peaks and
valleys and uh break them up into more
usable pieces I think is is huge the
number of the amount of development
that's precluded just because you can't
you know you can't turn your
spoon-shaped lot or or spoon shaped
section of dry land uh into a buildable
lot I think is pretty significant
um uh another thing I would say is that
the the density is uh ultimately going
to be a benefit to the community in
terms of the expansion of the tax base
um you know as an investor uh we we'd
like to see our taxes go down instead
they go up every year and if there was a
larger uh built environment for that to
be spread over I think that makes
business sense uh Mak sense from a
public investment perspective um some of
the key concerns uh have to do with
whether or not the infrastructure can
fundamentally support uh the development
and one of the things I would just like
to point out is that development doesn't
happen overnight uh and the the sizing
of the existing Water and Sewer
infrastructure was at some point based
rationally on the anticipated load that
we would be put on those systems and so
um just because we've set that that line
in the sand at one point in in the past
doesn't mean that we can't move it and
put municipalities on notice that as
they're thinking about their
infrastructure renewal uh projects that
they should be setting larger targets
that would promote density and that's
all I have thank you there any questions
from the committee
saying none thank you very much is there
anybody else that like to
testify all right I will close the
hearing on HP
459 recall the chairman and hand the
gavl back over you're in control
all right it is 153 I would like to open
the public hearing on HB
631 and recognize the prime sponsor
representative Alexander Murray
welcome thank you Mr chair and honorable
hble members of the committee for having
me back for the record my name is
alisandra Murray I represent Hillsboro
District 20 which is the town of
Manchester Ward 9 um so hb631 the bill
before you today seeks to address our
current housing crisis by allowing for
the creation of residential building and
mixed residential units within any
commercial lot whether that be new
construction or Rehabilitation of
existing uh infrastructure it also
ensures that those units would be
restricted by exist in local guidelines
for commercial structures regarding lot
Dimension and coverage as well as
Building height
standards while in this legislature we
often defer to local control our housing
crisis has reached such a level that we
cannot wait for changes to be made
incrementally on the local level we need
broad sweeping zoning reforms that can
start to solve this crisis now according
to the 2023 annual homelessness
assessment report from the US Department
of Housing and Urban Development
homelessness Rose in New Hampshire by
52% which was the highest increase in
the nation surpassing New Mexico New
York and Colorado the number of
unsheltered people in our state also
rose again in 2024 and National experts
say that the lack of affordable housing
is the number one cause of homelessness
in this country according to the
National or the New Hampshire realtors
association the medium cost for home
purchases has increased every single
year since
1998 the median cost is now at 480k
which is a 6.1 rise in cost from just a
year ago when the price also Rose by 7%
from the year before the median price
for a rental unit in New Hampshire
reached a record high of, 1691 in 2024
moreover as of July 2024 the medium
price for a single family had also
increased to the highest it's ever been
according to Red finin National real
estate brokerage nearly a third of all
home purchases in the state of New
Hampshire in 2022 were cash only
indicating indicating a clear wealth Gap
and who can actually afford to purchase
a home at this time rental prices have
increased at a rapid Pace since the
start of covid-19 in 2019 a two-bedroom
cost
1347 a month which has increased by
31% and I know we all know about the
high in crisis but I want to um just
continue to share this data for the
record um
the uh increases have been averaging
higher than the increases across the
country um specifically in New England
and from my own experiences I can tell
you that when my husband and I rented
our first apartment together a few years
ago was a 2.5 bedroom apartment for $900
a month and by the time we moved out 5
years later it was over $1,600 a month
and there had been no renovations or
Improvement done to the property in that
time renters are more likely to pay more
than 30% of their income towards housing
costs and nearly half of renters in the
Granite State uh declared being burdened
by the hous prices among those with a
household income less than 35,000 about
three out of four were paying more than
30% of their income towards rent so the
data here is clear the housing crisis is
not showing any signs of slowing down
and granite Staters are suffering for it
we need to take radical action now to
stop this problem from getting even
worse zoning reforms such as those
proposed in this bill are an integral
part of solving the housing crisis and
encouraging new construction which
according to the US Commerce Department
has significantly slowed in New
Hampshire bringing residential units
into commercial zones is not only a way
to expand the area for potential
building but also encourages the kind of
building that young people especially
want to live in and as we know New
Hampshire we currently have a problem
retaining young people and workers for
our economy that commercial units have
been zoned out of existence in older
neighborhoods and have never been
allowed in the first place in newer ones
is a real loss for residents kids miss
out on opportunities to build
Independence people have no choice but
to drive to get groceries or anything
else they might need even as something
as small as a carton of milk and there
are fewer opportunities to just bump
into people you know and actually be
able to build community where you live
these might seem like little things but
collectively they make life harder more
expensive and more isolating imagine how
many thriving home businesses there
could be if we actually encourage people
to go make them rather than creating as
much red tape as possible if we mix
commercial and residential zones we
lower the need for parking minimums
encourage walkability and create the
kind of communities our state needs to
thrive I'll be happy to take any
questions thank you representative
questions for representative
Murray I have two okay so um page
two line 18 section four municipality
provided paragraph 2 may require up to
20% of available ground FL space be
dedicated to residential uses are you
opposed to raising that I feel like 20%
for ground
floor is a little like unreasonable
maybe they could require up to 70% or
80% because the idea is is if you want
to build a walkable neighborhood you can
have the the shops on the ground floor
and then have the apartments above
that's the way I picture it um yeah I
absolutely I was wondering where you got
the 20% that's um I worked with um
someone on uh the language of the bill
housing Advocate but I would be happy to
make any changes and I completely agree
with you we've seen that kind of
building do very well in Bedford and
Salem where they're building these units
above um Sephora and the gym which is
great
I don't go to
Sephora so
um um and also line 20 through
203 it says that the municipality may
require the development include on-site
vehicle proper vehicle parking but the
property owner shall have full authority
to determine the location and size of
the parking lot for
residents doesn't that just like cancel
it out because won't the property owner
build the pro build the amount of
parking needed for the development
anyways and so the town can say oh you
need parking and the property owner if
they don't want parking they can like do
one spot you know I I I guess I don't I
don't see the purpose of that section if
if there's something I'm missing let me
know but again if you're okay with it
scratching that section like your
feedback be happy to scratch it I think
it's just trying to keep in line with um
the fact that this bill wouldn't change
any exist ing regulations that the
municipalities may have already for
these commercial zones so if they
already have parking restrictions for
these commercial zones that those would
still apply in the Residential Building
um so I think it's just kind of aligning
it with that but if you think the bill
could be simplified by removing that
happy to great thank you representative
Paige thank you Mr chairman I'm just I'm
just curious if you could provide a
little context for your decision
um in terms of in terms of the
municipalities that would be
impacted to align it with the urban area
designation by the US Census Bureau I
mean I think um you know when I when I
saw the title of this bill and then I
dug deeper you know I started realizing
that the communities I assumed would be
targeted it was a lot more communities
than that you know communities we might
not think of as Urban places like
Meredith or Lincoln or these other
municipalities um that are really truly
pretty rural places so I'm just curious
about your decision to use that
designation and and if you could provide
us some assistance and understanding
your logic there yeah I think you know
the intent is
to work in places where the
municipalities are more prepared to deal
with like a potential increase in um
that amount of building and the amount
of people that would be like residing in
such a mixed use um building um and to
take into consideration you know what
I've heard from some more rural counties
about what they would actually be
willing to um explore but again if
that's something the committee would
rather just open up to all
municipalities I'm I'm happy to do
so any other questions thank you
representative thank you very much um
chair would like to call on Matt
Mayberry
good
afternoon good afternoon once again
chairman committee members my name is
Matt Mayberry I'm the CEO of the New
Hampshire homebuilders
Association and I'm asking you to give
pause on this
bill because here are some of our
concerns from a homeb building
perspective and a provider of housing
that we as a state as we are tackling
these housing issues we will conquer
them We Will Conquer this
challenge but we also want to make sure
that those newly housed individuals have
a place to work so they can afford those
mortgages and afford those
rents the way the bill is written is
pretty with the broad definition of
commercial that could be commercial that
could be retail that could be
manufacturing that could be
biotech anywhere in there
because I can promise you right now
ladies and gentlemen that if you open up
all commercially zoned land for
residential use by right then you're
going to see a Scramble for Builders to
pick up industrial parks technology
Parks every strip mall in New Hampshire
these buildings are not the easiest to
finance as they are when you add a
residential component to it it could
make getting financing
harder often why do after 35 years of
being a real estate agent and real
estate broker is I'll counsel
individuals that if you have a multif
family building you can Kindom minimize
them and sell them
individually if you have a commercial
retail or industrial presence on the
first floor even the first two floors
even office
space to get financing for the
residential units above sold as
individual Condominiums will be nearly
impossible
you'll have some investors who will jump
in there but the folks who I think
you're trying to help will be priced out
of it because they have that come with
100% down or a sizable down payment in
order to get that and it'll be certain
covenants to go with
that if if municipalities wanted this
type of De development all they have to
do is just change it the rezoning to
mixed
use if the language in the bill narrowed
the definition commercial to
retail with retail or office on the
first
floor and Resident above we'd support
that I personally am
speaking for myself I'm a member of the
Rochester New Hampshire Economic
Development um
committee we talk to folks who want to
come to straford County to build bring
jobs they're asking two questions where
can we build our manufacturing plant and
what does our Workforce look
like we really don't want to have
residential units inside industrial
parks and that's where we're fearful
this is we may
go um I understand the immediate need
for housing residential housing I live
it 70 hours a week but 84% of our land
is forested and a total of 52% of New
Hampshire is protected under current use
statute
so maybe we should be looking elsewhere
other than Industrial and Commercial
parks and strip malls to build
housing thank
you questions for Mr Mayberry
representative
Gibbs thank you Mr shair and thank you
for coming to testify this afternoon yes
ma'am um You' stated your major concern
being about the difficulty of financing
in certain uh circumstances but since
the legislature does not have the power
to set financing standards shouldn't we
concern ourselves as we do in this bill
with loosening the uh government and
Municipal regulations that we can
control and thereby allowing more
housing even if it won't be built in
every area that this bill would allow it
will still be built in more areas
shouldn't we concern ourselves with that
it's all a matter of perspective ma'am
that we're a culmination of our life
experiences and we don't
compartmentalize when you walk in that
door and when you sit behind that
microphone we are a product of our
experiences and we're trying to bring in
manufacturing here we're trying to bring
in more high-tech we all applaud what's
going on in Manchester in the
Mills but when you look at some of the
industrial parks and Commercial parks
and Manufacturing do you really want a
housing development in there
also those are questions that you folks
have to ask
yourselves I'm just asking you to give
pause to the broad definition of
commercial maybe a little
narrower represent
Reed thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question there's a few pieces
here
um so as has been testified to by
variety of people including yourself um
a big piece I I disagree with many
people I don't think the only piece or
maybe even necessarily the largest piece
of solving the housing crisis is Supply
but a certainly a big piece and I I'm
having a hard time understanding why you
would on other bills say that we need to
increase Supply we need to increase
Supply but on this one opening up areas
and I want to be specific because I hear
you talking about residential
development as in creating residential
buildings and what I understand and I'm
I'm I will freely admit if I've missed
something in this bill is residential
use of a commercial building so if
there's a space above a commercial
building that can be rented out but not
building a residential building in a
commercial Zone that's not how I read
this so I don't understand why not if
Supply is the answer as has been
testified to repeatedly over and over
again why is not opening areas that make
no sense to deny people the right to
just sleep there why is that not
helping because to have a stable
tax-based representative you must have a
residential component and have that
offset by retail commercial office
technology communities have found that
if you live just on the backs of
residential property taxes they have
some of the highest taxes in the
state when you look at communities like
Newington and I think they're at like $9
per assess thousand now because they
have a large retail commercial
industrial base out
there are you done answering the
question Mr
M yes sir represent
GRE so if I'm hearing you right that
it's not anything to do with like the
safety of the people who would be living
in in a commercial Zone or anything like
that it's literally the difficulties
around taxes in a in the face of a
housing crisis where we are desperately
trying to make sure people have a place
to stay so they aren't forced out either
into the cold or into a out of the state
um that we just haven't figured out the
proper tax structure but isn't that a
secondary thing to figure out and
wouldn't the towns figure out how to
deal with that after the fact I mean
isn't it of primary importance to figure
out how do we Supply housing
representative I'm not not really sure
how that relates to his testimony in so
far as Mr Mayberry has said that he is
not against the premise of the bill but
would like to see the definition of
commercial narrowed down and I think
you're going away from the germanness of
what his testimony was covering I am
directly responding to his last answer
to my last question which is I said why
wouldn't this why would this be an issue
because I'm reading it differently and
he said because the tax so I'm saying
isn't tax a secondary concern next to
the prim concern making sure and I'm
asking for him if that's his
opinion a representative we're going to
solve this challenge together we're
going to bring more housing online we
must pick our heads up and look what our
state is going to look like 20 years
down the
road what type of tax base do you want
your tenants and your employees to be
living under if we only do this just on
the backs of housing we're going to be
back here 15 years from now saying we
need property tax relief because we took
all of our industrial parks and we made
them housing
developments I can guarantee you my
Builders will be in line to buy all of
them let the auction
begin but then 20 years down the road
when they're living in Florida and
Texas this legisl is going be faced with
what do we do because we can't bring in
any more Lonas any more army any more of
the industrial base that we
want here
manufacturing where does hitchner go
when we take the land AB budding them
and we put a Housing Development on it
all I'm asking you to do is perhaps
narrow this down to retail and office
that makes sense your employees can live
on the second third and fourth floors go
downstairs to work go to work in the
office why do they need to be next to
Sig saour or Lonzo
representative Gibbs thank you Mr
chair um you mentioned that um the home
buildings will be in line to purchase
the B the Lots where there are
industrial parks but wouldn't the
industrial park owners uh only sell if
that were more profitable than creating
industry in those industrial parks if
there was already an industrial park
with industry in it wouldn't they keep
it if that were more
profitable most industrial parks are
owned by municipalities and there are
two little words in this that changes
everything by
right so a town planning board or town
zoning board can say we want some mixed
juice over here that'd be great that's
appropriate for our
municipality they should be able to do
that but when you add the words by right
you take away the options from the
municipality to say what their town will
look like and say we don't care there's
an industrial park and there's a 40 acre
parcel on there we can put 80
condominiums on
there
uh would this bill Force anyone
including a municipality to sell an
industrial park to a home builder I
don't see that it does but the but
representative the two key words in
there are by right but would that force
a
sale a buyer and seller don't have to
agree to anything because I can walk up
to you and say I'll buy your home for
$10 by right I can do that you don't
have to do it no one has to buy no one
has to
sell but when you have that you know
residential overlay by
right and then you take it to town
meeting
and town me says yes we'll sell those
150 acres even though we'd love to have
a microchip plant in there like they're
doing in Charlestown New Hampshire right
now $64
million on doing microchips in New
Hampshire so I I
think I I has he answered your question
no one more one more followup all right
one more
does the term by right Force the
municipality to sell or does it only say
that if the land is already
available can the housing be built on it
I would argue with the
letter okay
um not a question I have a
question line 18 on page two what what
you're saying to me is that you would be
in favor of a bill like this if we
raised the percentage up to 100% on
ground level and excluded it solely to
retail and um what was it ret office
retail and office and it could also be
medical office and removing the parking
requirement that I'm sure the home
builders have testified and support of
doing that before too yes sir okay thank
you questions for Mr B representative
buio thank you Mr chairman um so well
thank you very much for your testimony
because I I I really actually like the
idea of this bill um you know we do too
so I you know I want to see something
you know like this happen and it's
actually kind of ironic that you
mentioned uh hitchner because you know
in my district includes Littleton New
Hampshire that used to have a hitchner
manufacturing plant and is now currently
a mixed use development with uh
commercial and residential and it got
rezoned as mixed use in order to allow
that to happen but that was quite an
ordeal and my town also has an
industrial park that was specifically
cited because it has the infrastructure
and everything needed for all of those
manufacturers which is actually kind of
hard to put together in some places so
it's very deliberately chosen so I guess
my question is I know um the chair uh
chairman was just talking about page two
line 18 but on page one line 27 it says
is located on a parcel zone for
commercial office retail or parking uses
um you know retail office I mean for
mixed use definitely makes sense but
nobody wants I mean well if you didn't
have a choice I do agree with
representative Reed on that you know
housing is housing but I don't think
most people if they had a choice would
choose to live on top of like a working
manufacturing plant um if they could
help it so would it would it help then
because there's earlier definitions in
this bill if it defined maybe what
commercial office retail or parking uses
were cuz when I first read this I didn't
read industrial at all I didn't think
that this would in any way allow people
to build anything in an industrial park
so is it a lack of definition or is it
just something else I'm missing sorry
for the long-windedness in our in our
view sir it was the lack of definition
because a commercial grade property is
five residential units or above a truck
stop is a commercial grade property a
supermarket is a commercial gr
property so with without the definition
of commercial being defined like Define
is that that leaves it a lot very open
to interpretation that was our only
challenge that's why I I didn't say no I
didn't say yes I just ask for you to
pause and please consider a def a
refinement of the word commercial please
okay represent
miles thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um if we can
go back to the piece about the the the
tax part um if you could just clarify
are you just saying that if we only have
residential buildings in our towns we
only build residential and we foro any
other commercial stores retail the
people who live in the town and 15 20
years down the road the people who are
trying to keep that town intact their
property taxes will have skyrocketed
because there will be no Industries
bringing money into the town and it will
be solely on the backs of the property
owners yes and no and I want to make
sure that I heard it correctly that you
know without Actuarial tables nor my
crystal
ball but when you look at municipalities
around our
state those who rely solely on property
tax
revenue tend to have high higher
property tax bills than those that may
be offset by some other factors now
there's always exceptions to the
rules
um of course my
pleasure representative
Reed
I'm so I I guess I'm still struggling to
understand this tax uh argument because
if if you have a commercial Zone and
you're allowing residential use you're
allowing someone to live in it it may
not be the whole building it may be just
the top it may be a piece it may be the
whole building but the assessment of
that property is still the property the
size the amenities of the property the
assessment the value of the property as
a commercially zoned structure that's
the assessment that's what it gets taxed
on so I'm not perhaps you would
enlighten me as to why I mean I
understand you're saying that if 's no
industry but you're just talking about
property tax and property tax is based
on the assessment which includes the
actual structure the value of the
structure including when things are
commercially zoned they are worth more
so where where is the town losing
Revenue if it's a commercially Zone
you're just allowing an extra use you're
not changing the zoning you're not
changing the
structure basically just letting people
sleep
there unfortunately life is as
complicated as just just going to bed
and waking up that you have to pay for
that somehow and all I'm suggesting is
when you look
at please get out of North Main Street
here in
conquer and head out to an industrial
park if this goes through by right you
could
have a clothing
manufacturer a 20 unit apart
building and you could have a medical
research
facility all on the same
street because it it's a commercial
grade
property and all and all I'm saying
representative is that you
know look 20 years down the road of how
do we want our tax
base we're going to work through this
housing challenge we're going to provide
housing we're going to do this you folks
have been very diligent the Chairman's
been very diligent he and I speak more
than I think he speaks to his
parents because he is on this every
single day I promise
you representative
Reed thank you Mr jiren thank you for
answering taking my question again um I
mean this is the second time I asked a
question and your answer really I don't
think addressed the actual question but
you said we are going to build the
housing now you represent the Builder
Association so are you saying that BAS
basically we meaning you all you want to
build the housing and not allow
currently existing structures that are
zoned commercially to provide any of
that housing because then you would have
a more Demand on your service that you
provide right if we're providing housing
on the in the existing commercial
structures then all of a sudden that's a
less Demand on you all building housing
so is that what I'm hearing you say
because that sounds a lot like what
you've been
arguing we we want your tenants and your
constituents to have a place to
work okay I
think representative
Gibbs thank you Mr
chair um while I don't think that the
term buy right requires anybody to sell
anything um uh I find that I cannot find
the term by right in the bill itself um
I find it in the analysis which is
basically a summary and description can
you tell me um where in the bill the
term by right is
down I'd be happy excuse me I'd be happy
to take a look at that and I'll send it
to you I don't want to take the
committee's time trying to reread the
bill for the fourth time uh to find two
words I'm happy to do so but if you have
the by right in the definition or the
analysis well that's someone's
interpretation of
this so they're smarter than I am thank
you very much for your testimony Mr
maybery I'm going to exuse you thank you
um next up Grace
Murray hello again and good afternoon Mr
chairman and honorable members of the
committee for the record my name is
Grace Murray and I support HB
631 I work as the political director for
New Hampshire youth movement we're a
nonprofit dedicated to getting the young
people of New Hampshire engaged and
working on issues that affect them
directly housing is is an issue that uh
is affecting all Granite Staters right
now but as the people of my generation
graduate college and start making a life
for themselves we found that homes of
all types Apartments starter homes and
shared homes are Out Of Reach this isn't
surprising as according to Pew rent in
the United States Rose 31% from 2017 to
2023 with too few homes available and to
few homes being built costs are
continuing to go up and up all the while
local governments are blocking
construction of homes that we need with
uh restrictive zoning
rules thankfully the housing system
doesn't have to stay this way though um
we can build more homes allow multif
family housing and utilize underused
commercial spaces we just got to cut
away the red tape and that's exactly
what this bill does building more homes
in commercial corridors is an important
step towards meeting the housing needs
of New Hampshire residents and helping
young people stay in New
Hampshire municip pales have had their
chance and it's time for our legislators
to step in and ensure that Grant Staters
can find a home please support HB uh
631 thank you for your testimony
questions from Miss
Murray seeing none thank you Paul Des
Shine welcome thank you
my name is uh Paul desan and I'm a
project manager for the town of
Newington and I've been asked by the
board of Selectmen to appear in
opposition uh to um House Bill
631 um basically comes down to two
specific issues uh one more generalistic
and one very specific to the bill itself
um first of all we believe that there
could be an unending consequences
relative um to the definition of of
rural versus uh urban areas uh I've been
told by some other source I believe may
be the manshire municipal Association
that this proposed Bill may only impact
18 communities in in New Hampshire um if
you take the classic definition of of
urban um that may be true uh but if you
go to the US Census Bureau and use one
of their graphic um uh visualization
tools you check the box for urban and
suddenly the entire Portsmith
metropolitan area pops up um and that
includes at least half of Newington and
and many other of the surrounding
communities so that in itself may be an
unintended consequence of this bill um
because I don't think a community of 800
people really is considered to be an
urban uh environment um but that's the
reality in which uh Newton operates and
may also be um exacerbated by the fact
we don't have our own ZIP code uh we
have to Port zip code so a lot of the
Census Data gets U shuffled back and
forth even though they have census
tracks and that sort of thing there's
still zip code uh uh
related the broader content of course
and you probably heard this uh before is
is the issue of local control the basic
tenant of local control is that those
closest to the issue are best positioned
to address such issues for their
Community now no doubt there's a housing
crisis in the Hampshire
and maybe there are other tools to to
deal uh with this
crisis we just don't think
that
totally eliminating uh in this case the
the local land use regulations uh is a
Panacea uh for that uh problem Newton
has addressed its local needs by having
a strategic plan by having all its
residential uses on the west side of
Route 16 and all smallest industrial
commercial spaces on the east side of
the balding Turnpike this has served us
well um and um provided a a stable and
healthy tax base uh as noted before and
uh has a uh a standard of living uh that
many people in the San uh in the seast
uh area um are envy and we hope to
continue that uh with the successful
practices that we've had so I would
Advocate uh opposition position and um
interim study or um inexp inexpedient to
legislate um based on those two two uh
issues um open any questions thank you
Mr desane for your testimony or
questions represent buo thank you Mr
chairman uh I have a question uh the
town of Newington what is the population
of uh Newington about 800 about 800 Ask
follow up go ahead um if this
legislation let's say had uh in addition
to the maybe it used a different
definition of urban maybe it said um if
the municipality had a population of
under I don't know 5,000 people or
something like that would Newington then
support
it in terms of its own interests I don't
know that it would support it but it
would find the opposition uh diminish
greatly uh if we weren't then included
in the uh the the definitional element
it still goes to the policy issue of
whether local control is still still
existing in
Hampshire representative Reed thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question I am I represent New Market so
I'm not terribly far from you um and
isn't it fair to say that Newington is
really an outlier amongst basically all
New Hampshire towns and what I mean by
that is um your tax rate is
significantly or at least it was a few
years back significantly less than the
average um property tax rate for most
towns and the reason is because while
you only have 800 people you have tons
and tons of businesses that help defay
that all that Revenue off of the backs
of the the property taxes that those
individuals have to pay and those
individuals tend to be on the wealthier
end um so it doesn't really look like
any town in New Hampshire isn't that
accurate that's been my
experience not to go broad a field to
other issues like uh education funding
um there are number of communities in
which Newton Falls into to it that were
considered donor towns uh so there are
other communities be they because
of vacation properties or industrial
Properties or utility properties however
their tax base mix has created uh an
enviable and and desirable tax base and
that's a planned strategy the town of
Newington uh implemented uh many years
ago and we don't don't see that we
should be penalized for for that uh
under this bill let me okay thank you
follow up yeah follow up um so I guess
what I'm getting at is the effect for
Newington in particular which has a very
small but really pretty much wealthy if
I may have put a fine point on it um
residential population small but well
off and a huge commercial use tax base
tons and tons of businesses um if you
were to allow those businesses to have
spaces that they rent out and provide
housing all of a sudden you have a lot
less wealthy people moving into
Newington even though I would think the
assessments for those commercially zoned
buildings would go up because now they
have rental units so they would be
assessed more but then now you have more
people coming into the town that are not
as wealthy as your current population is
that accurate I would disagree or that's
not necessarily a given
um first of all um the discussion
earlier where you were talking about
Redevelopment um there aren't many
properties in our commercial spaces that
are amable to direct
Redevelopment um you can't take the the
foxart mall very easily and convert that
into housing it's just not laid out for
that purpose um similarly um if you see
the development that's occurring in
Portsmith uh I don't see any lower
income moving uh into those uh
properties either so I think knon if it
had added housing uh caused by this bill
is not necessarily going to be of
something other than market
rate representative
Gibbs thank you Mr
chair um you mentioned that in Newton uh
the residential development is all on
one side of the spoing turnpike and the
Business Development is all on the other
side but wouldn't there be an advantage
to some residents of Newton might be
some new residents of new inton if there
was some housing that they could live in
where the places of employment are so
that the businesses are the places of
employment so that they could get to
their place of employment without having
to cross the spoing
turnpike a good supposition
but I think our strategy has proven that
in compatible uses residential uses in
the middle of a commercial district and
Industrial District
uh just doesn't allow uh lend itself to
the highest and best use of the
properties involved uh Residential
Properties are um always subject to no
noise odors congestion lighting all
those sort things in fact the
residential areas on the west side of
the Spalding still experience those
nuisances caused by the commercial
property on the other side of the
Highway uh we've had a particular long
and standing odor issue uh emanating uh
from that other side and we've even had
to set up a uh uh link on our website
where people could report order uh oders
so they could we could respond uh in a
timely fashion and investigate those
matters so um we just think that the
highest and best use uh of the
properties to the east of the Spalding
uh should remain in the commercial
industrial uh plan that we've exhibited
works okay follow follow up Mr Sher yes
thank you um but isn't it up shouldn't
it be up to the property owner to decide
whether a particular location is
suitable for the development of housing
or not and shouldn't it be up to the
people who would live in that housing to
decide whether it's worth it to them to
live in that housing if they have no
other place to go shouldn't that be up
to the property owner and the individual
well then you're really advocating the
doing away with zoning um that that's
the fundamental tenament tenament of of
um zoning and L's regulation is to bring
order to a multitude of desires by
property owners that conflict with one
another over and over again and that's
what gave rise to the
zoning
okay um thank you for your testimony
thank you very much for your time Mr
Nelson Dave Nelson
I think he
left Ivy
van good afternoon for what I think is
the last time today thank you so much
for having me back uh I am still Ivy van
I am still a land use planner I still
have lots of opinions about housing and
how we organize our public spaces uh I'm
in favor of this bill in general um
there are a couple of things I'd like to
mention that I think the committee
should think about as they work on this
bill I noticed that there was some talk
about well maybe we should increase the
percentage of of space that's not
residential in the buildings I would
Advocate against that particularly if
you are thinking as it seems from the
conversation that I'm hearing of
restricting this use for retail Offices
Medical Offices on the ground floor uh
the United States is over retailed New
Hampshire is over retailed um I would
cautious caution against requiring more
retail space on the ground floor of
mixed use buildings basically I think
that's one of those things like parking
that we're really bad at figuring out
how much of it we need and right now we
have in general too much of it the other
thing I'd like to say I think the issues
around you know does this belong in
industrial areas is an interesting
question I think it sort of it's likely
to be a caseby casee thing one way to
address that would be
to to if I were writing code that would
deal with this I think I would talk
about the uses that you are interested
in
seeing um in the same area and make that
clear a definitional change which I
think came up earlier today uh the other
thing I would like to say is I think
that rehabbing strip malls into housing
is a really swell plan and we should get
right on that um that's those are uh in
my part of the world and probably in
yours too we have empty spaces in our
strip malls they have giant parking lots
um that could accommod ate more housing
um you can make them a place by actually
putting down a street Grid in that giant
parking lot so that you end up with a
place in not a bunch of random buildings
um so I would urge the committee to take
this seriously work work on it a little
bit maybe add some
definitions um and support it in the
committee and on the house floor and I'm
happy to take any questions thank you
miss van represent Reed thank you Mr
chair thank you honor hble former
representative of IBM um this is your
area of expertise and so I'm glad you
brought up the strip mall thing because
as it turns out I happen to know for a
fact that the foxart mall has been
discussed in terms of producing um
housing inside of it so my question is
do you think that the argument that we
heard earlier being that this is your
area of expertise that allowing
commercial buildings to allow for
residential use within them that would
somehow drive out all business and then
towns wouldn't have any businesses in
them and it would vastly shift the tax
burden of the town somehow do you think
that's a plausible argument no I do
not I I think that I think there's a lot
of concern about well if we allow these
changes then you know terrible things
will happen which by the way is one of
the reasons that I come in and advocate
for these bills at the state level as a
person who works at the Town level it is
really hard for a town to take the jump
to make a change they need towns need
direction at the state
level thank you um representative buo
thank you Mr chairman um my my question
is uh in terms of uh are can you give
examples of other uh States or maybe
other uh communities which have adopted
similar legislation I remember reading
something that I think in Japan they
have um how housing as of right in all
of their commercial zones cuz they have
a national zoning scheme but do you um
know of something like here in the
United States where people have
implemented this well if you think about
any um any city or town that exists that
was built before
1970 they're all like this I mean if I
think about Cambridge Massachusetts you
got spas on every corner I mean there's
there are plenty of examples of places
that are good places to live
economically viable car light in some
cases that are exist because of the
ability to have both housing and other
uses in the same place do I think you
should put a fertilizer plant in a
neighborhood no I do not but do I think
that you ought to be able to have a
neighborhood bar yes I do I I think it's
crazy that we put bars out on the edge
of the highway where everybody has to
drive there and drive home
yeah so just so just quick qu I
absolutely agree with you I mean I think
a lot of parts of New Hampshire you know
everyone thinks of you know the quaint
Charming parts of our New England towns
that we all love and you're right they a
lot of them were built um not just
before you know 1970 a lot of them were
built even earlier before zoning even
existed right so I definitely sympathize
with that argument but modern Lifestyles
have changed you know people have
changed so in terms of contemporary you
know currently is is there a maybe
well-known example that we could study
or look at at regarding currently in the
United States where housing uh is
allowed by right in a commercial Zone uh
any any city that
has housing and uses and that's that's
Manchester that's new that's uh NASA
that's Milford New Hampshire um all of
those places allow housing in their
downtowns which have by definition other
uses those are remember I talked earlier
about the economic um effect of how we
build our places places that have mixed
use are economically Sounder than places
that don't we have plenty of examples of
this in the UN right now
unfortunately uh in New Hampshire we
have too many examples of places that
exist like this but where those uses are
existing non-conforming uses and what I
love about this is that this would
eliminate the whole question of existing
non-conforming uses in existing
downtowns um it's really imperative if
towns are going to be successful as
places for people to be live successful
economically for them to lean into those
mixed juuse areas that they already have
or allow them to be created if they
don't have them
Miss fan do you think that this bill
could be improved by simplifying it in
in and in in such a way that we can have
that it clarifies that the downtown
Peter Bros the downtown
Keen the downtown milfords is is the is
the goal and what we're trying to allow
rather than confiscating every
industrial plot in the state yes I think
it could be rewt I would be careful
about how I did that because one of the
things that we are acutely aware of is
you know what kind of development are we
getting along our state highways I'm
working on a project right now in Maine
where there's a state highway and right
now it's zon for Big Box commercial they
don't want that what they want is they
want to be able to pull their
downtown uh the sort of form and pattern
of their downtown down that down that
state highway so that they don't end up
with you know Market Basket followed by
Home Depot followed they want to see a
mixed use area so I'd be really careful
about how I defined that um and one way
to do it is I I'm pretty sure that most
of the codes in New Hampshire
differentiate between industrial uses
and Commercial uses and I think if you
had a definition in this bill that made
clear that you were not talking about
strictly industrial uses that it might
be um a better
Bill represent thank you for coming to
my TED
Talk representative Reed thank you again
Mr chair and thank you again for taking
my question if you permit me to kind of
be really philosophical for a second we
are talking about the ability to sleep
in a building by right yeah and when
we're talking about the ability to sleep
been a building by right in the middle
of the housing crisis being the biggest
crisis we are facing as a state with the
fact that housing is right up there at
the top of masa's hierarchy and that is
something we need to live especially in
a state that gets as cold as we do yeah
um philosophically
speaking what is the philosophical basis
other than what you mentioned like
fertilizer plants and like actual health
concerns actual health and safety what
is the Phil philosophical basis for
saying that people don't have a right to
sleep in a building that they have legal
access
to I actually would agree with you I
mean my only concern here is that um in
the interest of making clear what the
goal is that there be some language that
talks about what are the uses that we
think are incompatible with housing and
that's all um and again someone earlier
mentioned well nothing says you have to
sell that land and nothing does sell
that say that you have to sell that land
um so if a town owns an industrial park
and feels like it's likely to be used a
lot of them are empty um Peterborough
has I think a parcel that's about 78
Acres that's been standing empty well as
long as I've been paying attention which
is a really long time and it's got water
and sewer out there but there's no
industry coming I would love to see that
parcel turned into a mixed juuse area
and I think there are other places that
have that same situ ation okay thank you
miss van thank you for your testimony
thank you so much for having me and I'll
see you all next week I expect see you
next
week Matt
mushin afternoon chairman Alexander
members of the committee good to see you
again uh my name is Matt mushan I live
in Claremont and I serve as the advocacy
and engagement director for 603 forward
here to testify in support of House Bill
631 today uh because it's a critical
piece of legislation that would really
allow for the development of more homes
in commercial zones across New Hampshire
uh directly addressing one of the most
pressing issues we face which is the
availability and the affordability of
housing across New Hampshire our workers
uh teachers child care providers retail
workers and many others are struggling
to find homes that they can uh that they
can afford near their workplaces this is
a challenge that negatively affects our
communities but also our businesses and
our economy so by permitting multif
family housing and mixed use
developments in commercial zones uh
hb631 would provide a smart solution to
really just help bridge this Gap and um
there we think of it as like five really
simple uh reasons that this bill matters
one of them being that IT addresses the
housing shortage second being it will
lower our housing costs uh third being
it will shorten commute times and give
people better access to jobs
uh fourth opportunities for property
owners by unlocking economic potential
of underutilized commercial spaces um
and then lastly the benefits of mixed
use development we know that a lot of
young people want to be able to live in
places where they can leave their house
in the morning walk down the street get
the haircut grab a coffee uh do some
things and go back home without having
to hop in their car and uh Drive 20
minutes to do some of that New Hampshire
is facing a serious housing crisis as
you've all heard um and this really does
provide a solution that meets the needs
of both residents and businesses um and
it helps to ensure that the people who
serve our communities can afford to live
and stay uh in the places that they work
while also fostering stronger more
resilient communities across our state
so for these reasons we urge you to uh
support Bill 631 and I would take any
questions thank you for your testimony
questions seeing none thank you Nick
Taylor
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm Nick Taylor director for
housing action New Hampshire we're here
in support of the bill um although we
certainly are looking forward to working
with the committee because it seems like
there are some areas where we could
improve this I mean the real question
behind this is we all know we've have a
shortage of Housing and we're growing
and people are living longer the
question is where do we want to put it
the concept behind here being that
looking at already built out commercial
zones is a good place to look because
there's existing infrastructure there
the roads the water the sewer we're not
building out into our Open Spaces we're
building out into the places where there
are jobs where people can walk to work
where the infrastructure exists and
we're increasing property rights by
letting Property Owners develop things
as they see fit um a couple questions
that have come up around other states
Mont Montana and Arizona have both
passed legislation similar in concept to
this and we're happy to pull those bills
and get them to the committee for folks
to review um on the tax question New
Hampshire housing had contracted with
Urban three group to do some assessments
around value per acre in New Hampshire
mixed use development has the highest
value per acre in New Hampshire so in
terms of targeting sort of the tax base
to where things are the most valuable
mixed use is that based on New Hampshire
data and there's some really interesting
facts and figures in there um we
certainly have no opposition to the idea
of removing manufacturing or industrial
zones I think the intent here is to put
it near retail near office near walkable
areas where folks FKS want to live that
are within the health and safety
elements that are the root of zoning um
and then we do think generally speaking
that flexibility is helpful for
developers our members who are talking
about how can they make projects work
things that sort of put real specific
restrictions on them about exactly what
their first floor has to look like
exactly who has to be there is difficult
to make work as times change and so we
would just as a general matter encourage
the committee to think about flexibility
think about the intent here
and then help make it workable so happy
to take any questions and we'll provide
those follow-up items thank you for your
testimony questions for Mr Taylor
representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming in to testify this afternoon
um you mentioned that um it might be
better if the um uh permitted use were
limited to Commercial and office areas
but there's been a discussion of empty
industrial parks if there were an EMP
industrial park that was already served
by City Water and Sewer might it not
make sense to um change that over if
there's already a building to repurposes
the housing or to build housing on the
land if there's not a building
there no I think that's a I think that's
a good point and I think that also gets
back to the Restriction element of how
specific you want to get with this and
so you know putting in health and safety
barriers or or you know um barometers
there I think is a good idea but keeping
the flexibility so that if there is
opportunity locally that that would make
sense thank you for your testimony Mr
Taylor excent thank
you and last um signed up is Sam
Hooper wello again chairman Alexander
Vice chair co- members of the committee
thank you very much again my name is
Samuel Hooper I'm legislative counsel
with the institute for J this speaking
in support of House Bill 631 um I think
a couple of previous Witnesses have
mentioned things that could certainly
potentially be improved in the bill but
broadly we're supportive and I have to
be careful here I'm very conscious of
the Optics of someone with an English
accent coming here and saying other
countries do things really well but I
think it is I don't think we're worried
about that but thank you it is
particularly coming from Texas I'm
especially sensitive to that um but it
is the case that a lot of the places we
like to visit in other countries you
know if you go to Barcelona or a lot of
places there are places where you have
mixed use you have work rest and play
combined in a neighborhood you don't
have to walk you don't necessarily need
a car to function although you certainly
have one if you want but just having
that flexibility and freedom is really
good I think um as as previous witness
mentioned a couple of states do already
do this like they've passed bills and
hopefully we will see that but it is
frustrating as other people have said to
note that that just the sheer percentage
of existing places that are very
desirable to live would not be legal to
build today were they to be you know
were you to try and permit them today
you know huge sways of Manhattan large
part of Manchester New Hampshire large
part of Austin Texas where I'm from just
would not be legal because they were
designed you know pre-1970 when um mixed
use was taken for granted when you know
the idea that you would need you know a
car per individual in a household to to
to function in the economy just didn't
exists so I think you know it's very
good from that perspective um again we
at The Institute for justice come at
this from the perspective of property
rights um but we think that this is an
issue where hopefully people from you
know different perspectives can can
agree there are a couple of points I did
want to mention that did come up um one
of them was around the 20% of uh first
floor being reserved to retail I think
we all love to see those buildings when
there can be resale on the first floor I
will be wary of mandating any specific
percentage though because I'm very aware
that just the economics don't work
everywhere for that to take place like
you need a certain amount of foot
traffic and other things in order to
support that level of retail and if you
were to put in an arbitrary number what
that can actually do is prevent such
projects and penciling altogether which
isn't unintended consequence and isn't
something that you want to happen um
another witness previously mentioned you
know would you want a housing
development in a commercial zone or um
Alo or an industrial Zone um from my
perspective I'd be very loed to tell
anyone you know where you can put
housing and I think there's different
kinds of industrial as well you know
there's industrial smelting works and
there's Light Industry as well which can
be very good to have nearby where you
work um I think of some of the new
developments in East Austin close to
where I live where there are um you know
Artisan um furniture makers Brewers all
kinds of other things that are in dense
walkable areas with retail and housing
nearby so I don't think that should be
an impediment I think certainly we can
potentially tweak the definition and I'd
be more than happy to consult and give
any advice and guidance that might be
necessary or or helpful if that's the
case but I would be wary of trying to
restrict this too much generally we come
at this again from a property rights
perspective and we think the broader the
better um and finally I just go back to
the collective action problem people
have talked a lot in this hearing you
know opposing or being neutral on the
bill about local control and there is
always a time in place for local control
where the issues are only local but the
housing crisis of course is not a local
issue it's a Statewide it's an
interstate it's a national issue um and
the risk is if you have this Collective
action problem then local municipalities
will look to others to do the work I
mean you have all local municipalities
looking to others to do the work to Bear
the burden of taking steps to increase
property rights to to enable more
housing then no one does it and that's
how you end up in this position now so
um again I thank the committee very much
for their consideration of all of these
bills all of which we at The Institute
for justice support I'm very happy to
take any further questions that you
might have thank you representative
Hicks thank you Mr chairman thank you
for uh taking the question and
testifying today so um about the issue
of local control
the weal two in here talking about
designated as an urban area would you be
supportive of removing that has also
been suggested so that this could be
more broadly applied to more
municipalities in New
Hampshire I think philosophically yes we
would be supportive of that I think this
is one issue where when we talk about
the highest best use of land the market
generally does decide very well you're
not going to have a kind of very dense
um walkable place where you don't need a
car somewhere that is very rural and is
isolated so that's not something that
should necessarily be legally required
we think that the market can generally
control for those things so um I
certainly understand the principle
behind that because urban areas are
where you would most likely see these
kind of mixed developments that that we
like but I don't think it's necessarily
to codify in
law thank you very much Mr chairman okay
is there anyone else here to testify
forgot the bill number on HP 631
okay Mr Freeman
up Chris Freeman um so uh I think it's
uh it's great that the bill has a very
broad definition of commercial property
um I think at the heart of the bill is
the question of how much Freedom should
we give to property owners and the only
correct answer in my book is a lot um
one of the gentlemen who spoke before me
raised the issue of local control
arguing that um those who are closest to
the issues are in the best position to
address them and I agree with that 100%
which is why I believe that it should be
up to the property owners to solve those
issues um uh Mr Mayberry um I very much
appreciate all of your work uh in this
space but I I would like to offer a
slightly different perspective on one
point that you raised um you had
expressed concern about the um the huge
rush of demand for land that's currently
used for industrial purposes and if
that's true if there is huge pent up
demand for this land then what it means
is that that land's not currently being
used for its highest and best use which
ultimately is determined by markets and
not by voters or government
bodies um the bill also isn't just about
taking all of the industrial land that
we have and immediately converting it
into multif family housing um certainly
it opens the door for multif family but
it also opens the door for um the
organic formation of live work
communities
um and uh so when I when I think about
that I think you know well why shouldn't
we have the midrise multif family next
to the biomedical research facility uh
why shouldn't we see industrial parks
that actually have people strolling
underneath the the shade of the trees
like they showed in the developer pitch
deck I think that that would be great um
I I recently read a book by uh architect
and design theorist Christopher
Alexander who I'm pretty sure I'm not
related to and I don't think you are
either um but he talked about um the the
concept of scattered work and how do you
distribute work within uh your society
and how do you build a community around
work and he talks about the idea of we
have this question where do you live and
it's kind of a it seems simple on its
face but where do you
live there's an implication that we
don't live in the places that we work
right you go to work and that's not
living it's not life and um by by kind
of merging these spaces you have an
opport opportunity to to bring you know
that other 30% of your life um you kind
of back into the fold you can you can be
close you need to run home for lunch you
can take care of that you have kids you
can take care of that um but also the
the aspect of the pride that people take
in the places where they live versus The
Pride that people take in the places
where they work um and so when you have
a concentration of commercial to the
exclusion of residential uh those areas
tend to feel very sterile often over
times the the um you know facilities
become kind of neglected and it starts
to feel like a place where life doesn't
happen where you don't want to
go um I think the the gentleman that
spoke before me with the much nicer
accent to listen to um he talked about
the medieval cities of Europe and and I
couldn't agree more he actually stole my
example of uh Barcelona uh you know
let's look at some of these cities that
everybody in the world loves to travel
to where where life happened and formed
organically large ly before uh you know
we had master plan overlays that were
written by people with horn drimed
glasses and elbow patches uh that's my
stereotype of an urban planner um I I
think that they're really excellent
places to live and I think that the more
we can borrow from that successful model
the more human scale and human oriented
our communities are going to be uh and
then lastly uh one thing I didn't hear
anybody else's testimony but it does
seem to be anticipated by the bill uh in
the definitions it talks about adaptive
reuse as a development that R retains at
least two exterior walls of an existing
building and adaptive reuse is an area
um that I have a a special interest in
uh because it represents a a very
approachable uh way to Bringing new
housing online um which is by taking
existing buildings that have reached a
state of functional obsolescence and
turning them into housing um and the
reason that this is more attainable um
currently to to build from the ground up
a new multif family development runs
around 300 to 350
per square foot and where even as high
as rents are those projects don't pencil
out unless you receiving significant
federal subsidy so so you don't have the
development of market rate you know full
Workforce housing um or even kind of
mid-range or upper mid-range housing um
adaptive reuse on the other hand so
think about Mill buildings think about
buildings that um likely already exist
within commercial districts um you can
you can retrofit those for significantly
less we've looked at a few properties um
and priced out Redevelopment and if
you're just doing an interior retrofit
full gut back to the studs you might be
as low as $150 a square foot on on the
renovation cost so if you can acquire
that building you know 3050 $60 a square
foot um you could end up in there for
about 30% less than what it would cost
to buy raw land and build from the
ground
up thank you for your testimony
questions representative Hicks thank Mr
chairman thank you for the taking the
question um I might come at this a
little bit differently so I walk to work
every day um I bought the house next to
the where I work so I could walk to work
every day uh and I employe teachers and
childcare workers they can't walk to
work every day because they couldn't
afford to live in my neighborhood um I
am fortunate enough do you think that
the passage of this bill would help
potentially employers build housing for
their employees to create more s
opportunities like I have
I think so uh one of the other concerns
that was raised was when when uh new
businesses are looking to move into an
area they have the question of where is
their Workforce going to come from and
to me the idea of a live work Community
which is fundamentally what this opens
the door for answers that
question okay thank you for your
testimony is there anyone else here to
testify on hb631 seeing not none I'm
going to close the public hearing at 303
represent page you have time or
no all right so um at this point I
wasn't going to I was planning on doing
EXA I want to make sure you guys have we
have enough time to discuss it so um
we'll hold off to next week so um
regarding next Tuesday we have a work
session on a number of bills I haven't
noticed it yet but I was thinking um the
bills we heard today the bill on
parking representative Howland has a
bill in a subcommittee
um relative to density requirements in
neighborhoods
um are there any other bills that the
committee seen that we heard that you
think a work session will that we have
not yet disposed of that you think a
work session will um help enhance the
bill okay I'm thinking the for the four
today parking and the other density one
so we'll uh go ahead and go with that so
is there anything else for the
committee next Tuesday at 10 wel commitm
all right have a great week guys see you
Thursday for